ausländisch
[Musik]
alles in Ordnung hallo und willkommen alle
dies ist actinf live stream Nummer 47.0
es ist der 3. August 2022
Willkommen beim Active Inference
Institute
Wir sind ein partizipatives Online-Labor und
-Institut, das vermittelt, wie Sie lernen
und üben
können  Finden Sie uns unter einigen der Links auf
der Folie.
Dies ist eine Aufzeichnung und eine Archivierung und
Transkription und Live-Veröffentlichung.
Bitte geben Sie uns Feedback,
damit wir unsere Arbeit verbessern können.
Alle Hintergründe und Perspektiven sind
willkommen, und wir werden die Video-
Etikette für Live befolgen  Streams sind
alle Aktivitäten des Active Inference Institute
partizipativ, also lassen Sie
uns wissen, wenn Sie etwas beitragen oder sich beteiligen möchten, gehen
Sie zu
activeinference.org und klicken Sie auf die Links
, um direkt teilzunehmen und mehr zu erfahren
und einzigartiges Abenteuer in 47.
Wir werden
nicht wie üblich ein Papier diskutieren und gegenüberstellen,
sondern einen Ansatz mit mehreren offenen Augen haben
In Bezug auf zwei Artikel in dieser Situation werden
wir
zwei Artikel über
aktive Inferenz und Abduktion im Jahr 2021
von
Ati Vaiko Pieteren und Majid Beni lernen und nebeneinander diskutieren.
Außerdem werden wir eine aktive
dynamische soziale Kognition und aktive
Inferenz von Ines diskutieren  hippolyto und
thomas vans auch ab 2021
alle Videos
Punkt Nullen und ansonsten sind
Einführungen in diese Ideen und
zusätzlicher Kontext keine Überprüfung oder
Bewertung oder abschließendes Wort,
und wir werden
diese
Färbung eines hellen Rots für das abduktive Papier
und hoffentlich konsequent verwenden  ein helles Blau für die Inaktiven,
das den Raum offen lässt, damit neue Farben
und Kombinationen entstehen,
die einige Bereiche der Synthese demonstrieren,
und wir werden an dieser Stelle
mit einigen großen Fragen sprechen und unsere
Ziele durchgehen sowie zwischen diesen
Zielen lesen  was ein bisschen anders ist
als viele Live-Streams, werden
wir dann
Überblicksinformationen zu jedem Papier in
Bezug auf die Ziele, die Ansprüche und die Roa geben  dmap und
dem Abstract
gehen wir dann zu einem Hintergrund-im-
Kontext-Abschnitt
, der viele Informationen
über Untätigkeit, Semiotik, Abduktionslogik
und so weiter enthält
viel Zeit,
um mit hoffentlich mehreren Autoren
in den kommenden
Diskussionen zu diskutieren. 1.2 und vielleicht darüber hinaus, also
wollten wir heute ein großes Bild bringen
Kontext
sprechen über einige sehr interessante Threads
bieten ein wenig Hintergrundwissen, das
einem hilft, in diesen Raum einzutreten und es dann
bereitzustellen  eine anfängliche Gegenüberstellung und
Durchgehen dieser Papiere, die wiederum
jemanden dazu anregt, die Papiere zu lesen,
tiefer einzutauchen und
seine eigene Perspektive auf diese
sehr interessanten Themen einzubringen,
also kommen
wir zu den Einführungen,
ich bin Daniel, ich bin  ein Forscher in
Kalifornien
und ich werde in den kommenden Folien mehr darüber sprechen, was aufregend ist.
Ich werde es an
Dean weitergeben.
äh, guten Morgen, mein Name ist Dean, ich bin in
Calgary, und äh, ich glaube, ich war
vielleicht  Der verzerrte Verstand, der versucht hat,
diese Idee zusammenzubringen und
vielleicht ein wenig die Art und Weise zu ändern, wie
wir aktive Schlussfolgerungen betrachten, indem er versucht,
zwei verschiedene Papiere mit scheinbar
unterschiedlichen Volksschwerpunkten zu ziehen,
und dann
beide
auch die Verwendung aktiver
Schlussfolgerungen beinhalten  als methodik
zur situativen analyse und was sind
die implikationen dafür,
also finde ich das wirklich spannend
und ich gebe es an stephen weiter,
also danke dean ja stephen hier bin ich
in um toronto canada um
und ich bin  Ich
bin wirklich an diesen beiden Papieren interessiert,
weil
sie beide viel zu partizipativen
Ansätzen im Allgemeinen sprechen und die Idee,
wie Menschen sich in der Welt engagieren,
also die Fragen rund
um ihre Untätigkeit,
ist wirklich relevant, ebenso wie der
Artikel über Entführungen
Obwohl sie beide ziemlich unterschiedliche
Zeitungen sind,
sprechen sie mich beide ziemlich stark an, also ist das wirklich
interessant, also freue ich mich darauf
, das
irgendwie erkunden zu können.  Ich arbeite mit
partizipativem Theater,
Community-Psychologie, Community-
Entwicklung und multiskaligen
Entwicklungsprozessen, und ich bin wirklich
gespannt
, wie
diese wissenschaftliche Sichtweise
auf eine
eher praxisbasierte
partizipative Frage treffen kann, die i
Ich habe es mir angeschaut, also gebe ich es an Daniel zurück,
ausgezeichnet, danke euch beiden und Dean, danke noch
einmal für die vielen Monate der
Reise,
der vielen E-Mail- und Monat-
und Nachrichtenreisen, die wir gegangen sind,
weil ich hoffe, dass sich dies
entfalten und einbeziehen wird  Ein Weg,
der die Live-Streams
und die Art von Materialien, die
wir durcharbeiten, über das hinausführt, wo wir
hingegangen sind,
und
in diesem
Sinne werde ich den Dekan übergeben,
um einige der großen Fragen hier vorzustellen,
gut,
wenn Sie zwei ziehen  Papiere,
die
in Bezug auf ihr Thema nicht viel gemeinsam zu haben scheinen,
müssen Sie aus einem etwas
anderen Blickwinkel
angehen, um nicht nur herauszufinden, was in einem Papier enthalten ist, sondern
wie diese Papiere
verglichen werden könnten, also haben wir einige
Fragen zu der Idee zusammengestellt,
welche Rolle als Situationsanalyse
entweder ein Werkzeug oder eine
aktive Inferenz der Realitätsmethode spielen könnte
, wenn es darum geht, Dinge zu ziehen, die
weit entfernt und voneinander entfernt zu sein scheinen, und sie zu verwickeln
und so  Die Fragen waren im Grunde
, ob aktive Inferenz sowohl etwas sein kann, das etwas hält oder enthält oder
begrenzt, als auch das Ding, das
begrenzt oder gegriffen wird, was aktive
Inferenz ist, oder ob, was, wenn aktive Betonung
sowohl das Ding
, das enthalten ist
, als eine Trennlinie in einer Tabelle,
als auch  eine Zelle,
so dass die eigentliche Lücke, in die wir
tatsächlich mehr Informationen hineinstecken können
, wie das aussieht, wie es
sowohl als Einschränkung als auch als Trennzeichen
gleichzeitig aussehen würde, und ich denke, es ist dieses
Gegenseitigkeitsstück, das wir
herauskitzeln werden  die nächsten paar
livestreams und was ähnlich oder anders
ist, modeln in den griff zu bekommen und ein anderer prozess ist das modeln
danke steven do you wan
Um hier nichts hinzuzufügen,
nein, ich denke,
das deckt eine Menge davon ab. Das einzige, was
das x, das da ist, bedeutet, dass
Sie wissen, dass aktive Inferenzmodelle aktiv werden können,
um Frameworks zu modellieren, also kommt diese
Kontextualisierung des Begriffs um irgendwie
ins Spiel  spielen, aber wir werden
etwas später darüber sprechen, also ja, danke,
großartig, und
dies
ist möglicherweise eine der ersten
Folien zu unseren Zielen, da
sie hoffentlich dazu beitragen wird,
auf dieses Niveau zurückzukehren.
Das Meme
hier repräsentiert diesen Live-
Stream, der zusammenkommt
die zwei papiere in einer weise, wo wir
eine hand klatschen hatten,
jetzt werden wir das in
zwei zusammenbringen, du kannst den sound schon aus
dem live-stream hören, besonders wenn
du zuhörst,
dean, was würdest du über
rames beschreiben  oder wie würdest du
zusammenfassen, oh, und eine weitere Anmerkung, die ich
zu rna ames hinzufügen möchte, ist, dass wir wollen, dass es
umfassend ist, aber auch Videos hat
, die anhörbar sind und eine angemessene
zeitliche Dauer haben, sodass es viele
Slides geben wird  Es wird viel Text
aus dem Papier kopiert und es wird lediglich darauf hingewiesen, dass
das Video angehalten werden soll, wenn Sie es lesen möchten,
aber wir werden einfach
von vielen der Textfolien fortfahren, die wir nur
wirklich sicherstellen wollten  Der gesamte
Text war dort unsichtbar, aber wir werden nicht
alles lesen, also
fassen Sie bitte zusammen, über welche dieser
Ziele Sie
sprechen möchten. Sie wissen, ich werde nur
über die Art
der Wurzel von jedem sprechen  Eine dieser Kugeln,
die sich die
Instrumentalismus-Debatte über Realismus-Instrumente genauer
ansieht. Ich muss nicht darauf eingehen, was das
ist, wenn Sie daran teilgenommen haben
, wissen Sie, was wir beschreiben,
äh, verstärken Sie einen Ansatz mit zwei offenen Augen
wo ein Auge in dem Paar
aktiver Schlussfolgerungspapiere die inaktive
dynamische soziale Bedingung
und Entführung aufnimmt, während das andere
Auge, wenn das andere Auge aktive Schlussfolgerungen
als Integrator von beiden manifestiert,
weil wir glauben, dass es dies tatsächlich tun kann
, ohne es zu vermischen
, tatsächlich eine verursachen kann  weben oder a  Geflecht
und dann der dritte Aufzählungspunkt ist
die absolute Notwendigkeit, explizit zu machen, wenn
wir diese ersten beiden Dinge tun wollen,
um die zeitliche Tiefe von
Modellen zu verstehen, die tatsächlich
zwei Papiere mit scheinbar weit entfernten
Themen beinhalten würden, wenn wir aktive Rückschlüsse auf
zwei verschiedene Themen ziehen
und  Dann haben wir einfach
verschiedene
Dinge herausgezogen, die die Autoren zu
ihren Artikeln notiert haben.
Danke, und Stephen, wenn Sie
zwischen diesen Zielen weiterlesen
oder alles, was Sie möchten, von dieser
Folie
hinzufügen könnten. Ja, danke, Daniel, damit
Sie eines wissen  Eine Gruppe von Autoren sagt, dass Sie
wissen, dass sie sich wirklich mit
Instrumentalismus befasst,
und Sie wissen, dass es eine gültige
wissenschaftliche Perspektive ist, aber Sie wissen,
dass es sie gibt. Dann beschreiben Sie
diese Frage über den Weg zum
Realismus
und Normalismus, damit
Sie wissen, wo
die Idee dahinter steckt
Ein Papier, das Instrumentalismus ist, ist
der Weg,
uns in dieser wissenschaftlichen Arbeit sozusagen zu erfassen oder zu halten, was
gut kann  herausgefordert werden, ähm,
und wir würden Wege sehen, die wir
vielleicht brauchen könnten
, um das zu lockern, wenn wir in
partizipative Ansätze kommen, also etwas
dazwischen, das diesen wissenschaftlichen
Raum lockert und ein Übungsraum ist, also das
gleiche mit dem zweiten Punkt,
ähm,
wo okay ist  Instrumentalismus
ähm, du kennst den Weg nach vorne, also was, was
Verhalten ausmacht, wenn man in einer Nische
lebt, was Lebewesen ausmacht,
ähm, und wie lösen wir
den Weg nach vorne? Wenn es
also Widersprüche gibt,
sollten wir sie in Einklang bringen, wenn wir in einem
Team versuchen, dies zu tun  Verwenden Sie dieses
ähm, sollten wir einfach mit ihnen leben und
einfach vorwärts gehen,
ähm oder wo sollten wir sie tatsächlich
hervorheben, so dass dies in gewisser Weise versucht,
in einem ähm außerhalb von vielleicht dieser Art von
Laserfokus
auf den wissenschaftlich-
philosophischen Punkt zu denken und zu sagen, okay wann
wir versuchen diese in einen teamkontext zu bringen
sollten wir das etwas lockern
so
und so einfach mal hier erwähnen
um eine anwendung zu geben sollten wir dann auch eine
denken  über
aktive Prägungen, die vorangestellt oder
angehängt werden, wissen Sie, adaptiver aktiver
Einfluss, effektiver aktiver Einfluss oder
aktive Inferenzmodellierung,
Sie wissen, wie wichtig diese Klärung ist,
um dann
auch darüber nachzudenken, wie das Instrumentalismus-
Realismus-Stück auf
diese andere Weise verwendet werden kann,
müssen wir positionieren  ähm,
Sie kennen sich vollständig ineinander aus,
und wenn wir dazwischen
sind, wissen Sie,
dass es mehr oder weniger Zugang zum
Wissen geben kann, basierend auf dem Kontext, so oft in der
partizipativen Arbeit
verschiedene Arten von Praktiken, Sie wissen, dass
der Kontext der Schlüssel ist,
und dann diese Art  of spricht ein
bisschen zu meiner eigenen Vorstellung von der ko-kreativen
Arbeit und ich weiß, dass
Daniel sehr viel mit Teams
und
Dekanen, sehr viel mit Transformationen zu tun
hat
Sie möchten den Schmetterling stützen,
ohne ihn zu zerquetschen, da ist etwas
ziemlich Zartes,
also wie können wir das
manchmal
in Räume bringen, in denen es ein
c ist  o-kreativer Raum, Sie wissen, wo
Modellierung auf subtilere
kontextbezogene Weise stattfindet,
und
obwohl wir diese
wissenschaftlichen Definitionen und strategischen
Entwürfe und harten Analysen haben
und sie nützlich sind, wollen wir nicht, dass sie das
zerstören, was passiert,
und es gibt ein paar davon  Bilder da
, die
irgendwie dazu sprechen, und ich werde
es vielleicht an Dean weitergeben, und Sie können mit
der Probenahme
von Wasser dazwischen und dem Geist der
Lücke
sprechen. Ich denke, ich denke
, das war eine schöne Erklärung, und ich
denke,
wenn und wann  Wenn die Autoren
kommen können, werden wir
etwas Farbe darauf bringen können. Ich glaube,
wir haben, ich glaube, wir haben ein paar Anker in den
Boden gesetzt, aber wir haben nicht gesagt, wie viel,
wie viel fließen
kann zwischen diesen verschiedenen Knoten hin- und hergehen, und
ich glaube, wir
wollten genau hier das Dazwischen herstellen,
wie es oft heißt, achte auf die Lücke, das ist das
einzige, was dich in der U-Bahn töten kann,
weil du nicht
aufpasst  die GA  p und ich denke, die
Probenahme der Gewässer dazwischen
macht dasselbe, außer dass es einen
etwas anderen
subtilen Unterschied in Bezug auf die
Fließfähigkeit dieser Art von Lücken bietet, also denke ich,
dass es wirklich interessant wäre
, wenn wir das als unser Portal verwenden würden  wie
wir Dinge zusammenbringen
und sie zum
Tanzen bringen könnten, wenn sie sonst
auf Stühlen auf der gegenüberliegenden
Seite des Raums sitzen würden, das könnte ein interessantes
Gespräch sein, um in den Punkten eins und
zwei zu beginnen.
Danke euch beiden und dem einzigen Kommentar, den ich machen werde
Fügen Sie hier
diese Diskussion hinzu, die wir über die
Adjektive geführt haben,
die der adaptiven affektiven etc. aktiven
Inferenz
vorangestellt sind, und dann auch den Fokus, den Sie
auf das Suffix gelegt haben, dass x und die
Klammern
aktive Inferenz als eine Instanz
oder einen Fall oder eine Realisierung
aktive Inferenz darstellen  Rahmen der aktiven
Inferenzprozesstheorie, was
folgt, und das erinnert mich wirklich an
linksverzweigte und rechtsverzweigte
Klauseln in Grammatik und Syntax
und daran, dass es eine Basis c gibt  Lause,
was ist unsere Basisklausel und was
verzweigt sich dann davor, während und nach Ich denke,
es gibt einen sehr reichhaltigen Raum, und ich
mag diese verkörperten
und flussbasierten Metaphern wirklich, die uns helfen,
ähm
so sehr zu verstehen, dass dies
in den
Papierübersichten nur einige Metadaten sein werden und
Beschreibungen zu den Papieren, bevor wir uns
im Kontext auf den Hintergrund
zurückziehen und dann zu den Papieren
übergehen, die ihre Hauptpunkte durchgehen,
also werden wir nicht die Zusammenfassungen lesen, die
sie
beide natürlich für diese Papiere verfügbar sind,
hier ist die Zusammenfassung für  aktive
Schlussfolgerung und Entführung,
hier ist die Zusammenfassung für inaktive dynamische
soziale Kognition und aktive Schlussfolgerung,
hier sind die Schlüsselwörter für diese beiden
Artikel
Schlüsselwörter
Abduktion aktive Inferenz
Prinzip der freien Energie zuerst und pauschale
triadische Beziehungen und durchbohren
Lassen Sie uns zu den Zielen
und Behauptungen
des Entführungspapiers gehen,
also
Dekan, würden Sie gerne
eines der Ziele des Entführungspapiers abdecken,
was ich gerne tun würde, ist nur eine Art
Vorhersage, was
beide Papiere anstreben und
das  Sie werden ein Schlüsselwort im
zweiten Aufzählungspunkt dieser hier sehen, das
Allianz ist, und dann gibt es Wörter, die
Sie in der anderen Zeitung sehen werden,
wo sie wieder sagen,
wir wollen, dass die Dinge zusammenkommen,
aber wir wollen  Seien Sie vorsichtig, wie wir dieses Zusammenkommen
beschreiben, wir wollen nicht,
dass es metaphorisch
als Verschmelzung als ein Rückgängigmachen von
zwei oder mehr Dingen wahrgenommen wird, von denen wir glauben,
dass sie eine
assoziative Um-Beziehung haben, und so denke ich, wenn
Sie das durchmachen  Ziele der beiden
Artikel Wenn Sie ein wenig zurücktreten, werden
Sie sehen, dass die Autoren beider Artikel
eine harte Ex-Erklärung darüber abgeben, auf welche
Beziehung
sie uns aufmerksam machen möchten, und
das ist etwas, was sie beide tun  Zeitungen
teilen, es ist eine starke Betonung  Das Thema
Beziehung ist ein
großartiger Punkt, und beide sind sehr
reich und kraftvoll geschrieben,
und hier sehen wir Allianz und Loyalität,
und sicherlich wird es
in beiden Artikeln viele Diskussionen
darüber geben, unterschiedliche oder teilweise
verwandte Ontologien und Vokabularsätze
und unterschiedliche Denker und unterschiedliche Threads zu integrieren
der intellektuellen entwicklung können
diese zitate aus dem papier gelesen
und natürlich in dem papier erweitert werden
,
aber wie dean sagte, liegt der fokus dieses papiers
auf der intellektuellen allianz
zwischen aktiver inferenz und dem
prinzip der freien energie fep und in erster linie auf der arbeit von
cs pierce
in Bezug auf  Semiotik, Pragmatik,
Grammatik, Abduktive Logik, das ist das
Ziel. Die Synthese bringt diese
beiden auf eine synergetische Weise zusammen
und gibt Bedeutung, Stephen,
ja, und folge einfach dem, was
du sagst, in diesen beiden Papieren und
insbesondere in dem abduktiven
, das einen Weg gibt  sich
Bereiche anzuschauen, die für Computer wirklich schwer zu
simulieren sind, ähm und
Die Art und Weise, wie Entführungen stattfinden, oder
insbesondere bei Menschen, ist
sehr raffiniert, und ich denke,
es ist wirklich hilfreich, dann die
Semiotik zu sehen, die
in der
Theatersonographie und im Bühnenbild tatsächlich viel verwendet wird,
um den Pragmatismus so
mit einer mit einer
wirklichen Theorie einzubringen  Das ist, wie Sie wissen, transzendiert die
Wissenschaft oft richtig. Es wird oft in
anderen Bereichen verwendet, z. B. in
den Naturwissenschaften. Es hat eine gewisse Verwendung dafür,
aber es wird oft in den Geisteswissenschaften verwendet.
Ich denke,
dies spricht zu diesem Stück darüber,
was diese Art von geheimer Sauce offenbart
diese Art von Hit in der Seele, die
normalerweise fehlt, und in Aktion
gibt es auch so etwas wie diese
großartigen
Behauptungen der Zeitung
sind überall in der Zeitung, aber nur um
einige der wichtigsten Behauptungen hervorzuheben, die
sie behaupten, dass das Ziel, das sie sich
gesetzt haben
Zwischen der Arbeit der aktiven Inferenz und
der Entführung und semiotischen Perspektive zu machen,
scheint sie zu behaupten, dass dies
machbar ist, und dass sie eine
Initiale liefern  Skizzieren Sie dafür
in dieser theoretischen theoretischen
Integration des Neuen und des Alten
etwas Rotes etwas Blaues etwas
Neues etwas Altes
und die beiden Rahmen, das Neue und das
Alte,
sind die modernen Instanziierungen der
Neurowissenschaften und der Kognitionswissenschaft,
die durch ein Prinzip der freien Energie
und auf dem dargestellt werden  alt Eine historisch korrekte
und präzise Interpretation der abduktiven
Schlussfolgerung einschließlich der Bedeutung
der Ökonomie der Forschung Alle Dinge, auf die
wir zurückkommen werden, wollte nur
die Behauptungen dort klarstellen. Kann ich nur
eins hinzufügen? Ja, bitte
ganz schnell, also theoretische Integration
dort i  was bedeutet, wenn Sie zurückdenken können
, als wir über unsere Ziele sprachen, stellt sich
nun die Frage, was die
Autoren sagen
Ich möchte
diesen einen Schritt zurückziehen, weil ich denke,
dass das wieder passieren wird, wenn wir uns das
ansehen  Bei der anderen Zeitung
verwenden sie eine andere Nomenklatur, aber
sie werden dasselbe sagen, und
wieder
ist es schwierig, die Gemeinsamkeiten zu erkennen, es
sei denn, Sie und Sie müssen
sie sich ausdenken,
Sie müssen sie nur im Text
bemerken  zwei verschiedene Arten von Wäldern
und ein Hinweis darauf, dass sie
beide in gewisser Weise aktive Inferenz
als Integrator sowie als
Differenzierer verwenden. Wir erstellen ein
integriertes Modell interner und
externer und umfassender Zustände,
indem wir sie differenzieren und dann
natürlich integrieren  und Differenzierung
werden
in der Mathematik auch gemeinsam mit der
Integral- und der Ableitungsnotation verwendet, also
werden viele Dinge
zusammenkommen, ähm,
Steven, deine Hände sind immer noch hoch, ja, bitte,
ja, nur eine Sache. Ich denke, das
ist wirklich hilfreich, darüber zu sprechen
Neurowissenschaft in dieser computergestützten
Neurowissenschaft und um das hervorzuheben,
weil ich denke
, dass
etwas die Realität in der Welt da draußen ist,
die Kultur da draußen,
wo diese Ideen sind  Es kursiert,
dass die
Neurowissenschaft im Grunde durch aktive Beeinflussung auf den Kopf gestellt wird. Die
Neurowissenschaft als Feld,
wie die Leute verstehen,
ist
eine Art
deduktiver
Prozess, bei dem Dinge hereinkommen und
dann bewertet und
konkretisiert werden, im Gegensatz zu dieser
vorausschauenden Reise, also denke ich, dass es
wirklich sehr nützlich ist
denn das ist etwas, mit dem
wir alle konfrontiert sind, und ich denke, was ich auch
bemerkt habe, als ich mit einigen
Neurowissenschaftlern gesprochen habe, ist, dass sie
tatsächlich eine existenzielle Krise hatten und sich teilweise oft verschoben haben,
indem sie inaktive
Behauptungen aufstellten und wirklich prüften, ob  Es gibt inaktive
Behauptungen, wie kann ihre Arbeit mit den
Neurowissenschaften
so zusammengehalten werden, also
gibt es
hier einen Teil, der sich auf das Allgemeine bezieht, und
dieser allgemeine
Teil ist wichtiger,
wenn wir anfangen, unseren
aktiven Einfluss aus
den Fachbereichen herauszubringen  wo es eine Art
Enklave ist und seine Spielregeln
bekannt sind und man sich in den Bereichen befindet, in denen die
Leute gut Neurowissenschaften sagen  Ich weiß, was
das bedeutet,
und los geht's, also vielen Dank, danke,
das Papier hat relativ wenige Abschnitte,
es hat eine Einführung
, dann präsentiert es
eine Paarung
von aktiver Schlussfolgerung im Lichte der
Entführung,
Abduktion im Lichte der aktiven
Schlussfolgerung,
leicht schräger Hinweis auf nichts in
Biologie macht Sinn, außer im Licht
der Evolution oder außer im Licht von
etwas, und das sind zwei Lichter
zurück zu diesen Inseln, was der Raum
dazwischen ist,
und dann gibt es eine Diskussion
über die Ökonomie der Forschung und ihre
Einbürgerung durch freie Energie und die Schlussfolgerung
und das  Durchbohren Sie Kaninchenlöcher, die tief sind.
Wir werden in Kürze auf einige eingehen und
auf das inaktive Papier
eingehen. Hier werden wir also die
Ames-Behauptungen und den Fahrplan des inaktiven
dynamischen sozialen Kognitions- und aktiven
Inferenzpapiers beschreiben.
Das Papier präsentiert eine zwei-  Ziel ist es
, neue Konten zu analysieren
, die Aktivismus mit schlussfolgernden Konten vermischen,
und zu erklären, warum dies
Widerspruch beinhaltet,
ist das erste Ziel
und das se  Das wichtigste Ziel ist es,
die einzig vernünftige Kontoverknüpfung im
Aktivismus und inferenzielle Konten anzubieten,
insbesondere in diesem Fall der sozialen
Kognition.
Also
ja, bitte nein, raten Sie, was ich gehofft hatte.
Könnten Sie jetzt das Wort
für
uns lila verlinken?  Das
Dazwischen zu beschreiben, dass Stephen sehr gut
betont hat, bevor wir tatsächlich
anfingen, uns
die Papiere selbst
anzusehen, ja, es ist dazwischen, ja,
es ist großartig, und tatsächlich wird es
durch Ihre Anfrage und die
Folienplattform zu einem aktiven, dynamischen
sozialen Stigma
und so
das ist ein Proof of Concept für was,
aber das ist das Ziel dieses Papiers. Okay,
sie haben auch viele Behauptungen
während der Diskussion artikuliert,
und sie verwenden tatsächlich eine sehr klare
Notation, um die spezifischen Behauptungen
aus anderen Arbeiten und aus ihrer eigenen Arbeit zu beschreiben
und darüber, welche Behauptungen  und Hypothesen
haben welche logische Beziehung,
ähm
sie werden Behauptungen über die
Natur der Erkenntnis und ihrer machen  Auf der verkörperten
Basis werden
sie einige
der Behauptungen diskutieren, die sich auf die soziale kognitive Nische des Menschen beziehen,
und über die Bedeutung der Nischenkonstruktion für die
Beziehungskultur
sprechen, und dann werden sie
über die Theorie des Geistes
und über die Kompatibilität oder
Widersprüche sprechen
Im Zusammenhang mit der Verknüpfung
inaktiver
Behauptungen mit
Theory of Mind oder Inferenzrechnungen legt
der Fahrplan des Papiers
viele dieser Ziele und
Behauptungen recht klar dar. Sie beginnen mit einer
Einführung
und stellen eine
neuere, wenn auch einflussreiche Arbeit auf dem
Gebiet der aktiven Inferenz vor, nämlich das
Framework zum Denken durch andere Köpfe
ttom
und sie, wie sie sagen, sezieren diesen
Bericht
, um zu versuchen, die Art und Weise auseinander zu ziehen, wie
ihrer Ansicht nach
die inaktiven und die schlussfolgernden
Zählungen zusammengebracht wurden.
Sie haben auch eine Figur, die eine
Markov-Decke beschreibt, die ein
Konzept sein wird, das in beiden eine wichtige Rolle spielt
ihrer Papiere
Abschnitt 2 etwas zu geben hat die
Zurückweisung inaktiver Schlussfolgerungen t  Durch
andere Köpfe werden
sie zwei Annahmen verwenden,
nämlich dass sich soziale Kognition auf
mentale Repräsentation reduziert, und zweitens, dass
soziale Kognition von Geburt an fest verdrahtet ist,
und sie werden
beiden Annahmen widersprechen und in ihrer
Opposition gegen diese Annahmen,
die durch Unteransprüche gestützt werden  und Beweise
, die sie zu ihren
umfassenderen Schlussfolgerungen führen werden,
sie werden die Theorie dynamischer Systeme verwenden
und darüber sprechen, wie
dst mit einem Aktivismus in Bezug
auf seine Kompatibilität verbunden werden kann und was diese beiden
Rahmen einander innerhalb einer
instrumentalistischen Lesart bieten
und  dann diskutieren sie aktive
Inferenz speziell im Kontext der
Theorie dynamischer Systeme einerseits und
inaktive
Kognition soziale Kognition
andererseits, das ist die inaktive dynamische
Silbentrennung, die
sie mit ein paar Zahlen
über Ähnlichkeiten und Unterschiede
zwischen sozialer Inaktivität im Allgemeinen beschreiben werden  wie
außerhalb der aktiven
Inferenz konzeptualisiert und dann sind sie es  Ich
werde visuell vorstellen, wie aktive Inferenz
dieses Bild bereichert,
und dann haben sie eine sehr interessante
Tabelle, die zwischen oder zwischen
Phänomenen unterscheidet, die in der natürlichen Welt
und beobachtetem Verhalten in der natürlichen Welt beobachtet
werden  Hintergrund im Kontextabschnitt,
also werden wir in diesem Abschnitt des Punktes
Null
sicher einige Zitate aus dem Papier verwenden,
aber wir werden auch einen Schritt zurücktreten
und nur die Spitze des
Eisbergs der Wissenschaft und der
Forschung demonstrieren  die wir bis
zu diesem Punkt durchgeführt haben, um
hoffentlich
den Zuhörer oder Leser zu begeistern
und einen Kontext zu diesen
sehr tiefen Themen zu schaffen, die
in den Papieren angegangen und angenähert werden
Ich denke nur, ich denke, dies ist ein
spektakulärer Moment, um zu sagen,
okay, also
Hintergrund und Kontext, also reden wir
vielleicht über
die zeitliche und die physische
Umgebung,
also tha  Es ist jetzt etwas, das wir
situativ analysieren können,
und wieder spielt
es keine Rolle, ob Sie aktive
Inferenz verwenden oder ob Sie ein
Modell verwenden oder ob Sie
professionelle Initiativen programmieren.
Unterm Strich versucht jeder
,
die Situation
durch eine Analyse herauszufinden  Methode und und und
ich würde mir vorstellen, dass jede dieser
Methoden mehr oder weniger praktikabel ist,
je nachdem, wie die Situation sowohl
zeitlich als auch physisch ist,
also denke ich,
dass das die entscheidenden Dinge sind, wir
sagen nicht, dass jede dieser
Papiere gut oder schlecht ist
Wir sagen, dass sich jede dieser
Zeitungen auf eine andere
Kombination aus Hintergrundkontext konzentriert,
mindestens zwei. Wenn wir also die beiden Dinge
zusammenziehen, können wir nicht sagen
, dass es
dasselbe sein wird wie wir  kommen Sie
auf unsere Ziele als Menschen, die sich jetzt
die beiden Papiere nebeneinander angesehen haben
, die eine ganz neue
Einheit schaffen werden,
danke
, um diesen Hintergrund und
Kontext abzuleiten  In diesem Abschnitt wollte
ich mich auf einen meiner Lieblingsdichter berufen,
William Blake,
und Blake schrieb:
Gegensätze sind positiv. Eine Verneinung ist
kein Gegensatz.
Verneinungen sind keine Gegensätze. Gegensätze
existieren gegenseitig,
aber Verneinungen existieren
nicht  für immer und ewig
ende
widersprüche in diesem blakeyschen vierfachen logischen rahmen sind in der tat
teil einer dialektik und sie existieren
als funktion voneinander wie konvex
und konkav oder wie schwerkraft und
strahlung, wie es buckminster fuller annehmen könnte
,
und so negationen in diesem poetischen
Rahmen
sind diejenigen, die
nicht existieren,
während a und b im Gegenteil sein können,
während a und nicht a eine andere
logische Beziehung haben und diese Art von
vierfachem logischen Ansatz
zum Erkennen des Zustandsraums und der
Wahrheitsansprüche, die mehrere nebeneinander gestellte
Behauptungen haben können
untereinander
ist auch in vielen Weltwissenstraditionen
um fo vorhergesagt  Zum Beispiel die Kata Scotty
und dies ist ein logisches
Werkzeug und eine Methode, die
seit sehr langer Zeit in den dharmischen
Traditionen des indischen Kontextes angewendet wird
, die das liefern wollten, und auch
mit diesen Bildern, die jeder von
Ihnen gerne erkunden kann
hat das Händeklatschen oder eine Person
, die den Spagat
macht, mit Widerspruch und Verneinung zu tun
?
es gibt da gibt es die
Widersprüche sind konstruiert, wenn
das Sinn macht,
ähm, und das wird auch
durch unser Leben verkörpert und inszeniert, also könnte es gut sein,
wie wir als Baby wissen, dass
die Morphologie des Kindes in
verschiedenen
Stadien in verschiedenen Kontexten die Möglichkeiten gibt
, situativ zu etablieren
Bewusstsein
und die Widersprüche darin,
wenn die Dinge kodifiziert werden, also hast du
diese diese
diese situationsbedingten
ähm
Prozesse sind irgendwie das, was
wir in diesem fortlaufenden Modellierungsfluss machen, die
Art von Praxisfeldern
in diesen verschiedenen Artikeln, die sie untermauern
was wir irgendwie
verkörpern und worauf wir uns einlassen und wir lernen
und das ist es, was wir irgendwie
intuitiv modellieren, so dass wir ein
Gefühl dafür bekommen, wie wir modellieren sollten,
in diesen Situationen die Widersprüche zu sein,
aber dieses Modellieren
oft und das ist die Gefahr,
wenn  es wird
von jemandem mit seinem Modell überwältigt,
d.h.
jemand ist in seiner Welt, der modelliert,
wie es ist, er selbst zu sein, oder versucht,
es zu verarbeiten, er geht zu einem Berater
mit seinem Modell und dieses Modell
wird verwendet, um ihn an das Modell anzupassen,
und dann an diesen Berater  wird uns sagen,
was ihr Problem ist, wie es gerahmt ist, also
denke ich, dass dieses Modellmodell in
ähm
hier ziemlich relevant ist, weil Sie wissen,
sobald diese Widersprüche
festgestellt sind, könnte es durchaus sein, dass
es ein Mo gibt  del innerhalb dieser Domäne erstellt,
und dann kann jemand, der nicht unbedingt
in dieser Domäne
ist, dem Modell zugeschrieben werden, er weiß nicht,
was das Spiel ist, er ist nicht
dabei, und das Modell übernimmt, so dass eine
Art Übergang zu den Splits erfolgt
denn dann, okay, wir haben zwei Dinge,
sie sind zusammen
, wir reden darüber, ja, lass uns
dich öffnen und du hast eine Haltung,
okay, also bin ich etwas und irgendwann ist
es so, als wäre das keine Haltung, Bruder
, das ist  Das ist eine Spaltung, in die
Sie geraten sind. Sie müssen vorsichtig sein,
also sind Sie auf diese Idee eingegangen, dass
Sie die Dinge jetzt öffnen, wenn sie
eine Sache sind, mit der sie beginnen, wenn sie eine
Haltung haben, die sie hatten
In gewisser Weise haben sie sich so gespalten, dass
sie jetzt
voneinander isoliert sind. Ich
nehme an, wir versuchen hoffentlich, einen
Weg zu finden, sie weder in eins zu drängen, noch haben
sie sich getrennt, vielleicht haben sie eine Haltung
dazwischen  ist äh irgendwie agil und äh
bezieht sich in diesem Fall auf Realismus und
ins  Trumentalismus, der einige breitere Themen widerspiegelt,
danke Dean,
nur ganz schnell, viele Leute haben
den Yogi-Baronismus gehört, wenn Sie
eine Weggabelung sehen,
nehmen Sie sie und ich weiß, dass mit
viel des Begriffs
Joint gekommen ist  zum Beispiel eine Menge gemeinsamer Wahrscheinlichkeit,
und daher ist die Idee der Aufteilung
hier wirklich gut, um metaphorisch
gesprochen zu werden, denn
wenn Sie
etwas mit aktiver
Interferenz betrachten und davon ausgehen, dass Sie
in einem Teelabyrinth-Experiment gut nach
links oder rechts gehen müssen  Menschen
können eine Weggabelung sehen und es nehmen
, das ist eine Art Dauerwitz,
wenn du eine Gabelung in meinen Beinen
siehst, nimm sie nicht unbedingt,
du musst einen Orbee wählen, du kannst
das Ganze nehmen, und ich denke, das ist es, was
Blake  versucht mit dieser
Übung aufzuzeigen und das ist ein Widerspruch.
Nein, wenn ich Utensil auf der Straße sehe, kann ich es
nehmen, aber wenn ich nicht offen
für die Idee bin, dass Gabel nicht nur
links oder rechts bedeutet,
dann bin ich es  bereits selbstbeschränkt in Bezug
auf wh  Ich teste gerade, was ich
situationsanalytisch analysiert habe.
Vielen Dank, in Ordnung, in die
direkteren Schlüsselwortstücke.
In Aktion von der
Website thisdefinitions.net ist eine Aktion eine der möglichen
Arten, Wissen zu organisieren und die
Formen der Interaktion mit der Welt
inaktives Wissen  ist Wissen,
das durch Handeln entsteht und
auf motorischen Fähigkeiten aufgebaut ist, wie z. B. das Manipulieren von
Objekten beim Fahrradfahren oder
Sport, das ist nur eine von vielen
Definitionen, die bereitgestellt wurden.
Wir hatten auch mehrere Live-Streams und
Papierdiskussionen über eine Aktion in aktiver
Inferenz
Zum Beispiel
im aktiven Live-Stream Nummer
sechs vor langer Zeit, als wir 2020 überhaupt über Ramstead diskutierten.
Eine Geschichte von zwei Dichten.
Aktive Inferenz ist eine aktive Inferenz
In gewisser Weise sagen wir genau diese
Diskussion hier ist eine Folie aus
diesem Live-Stream ähm
mit ähm von der Hippolyto-Zeitung
und  hier hatten wir den durchdringenden
Dreiklang und wir hatten die Symbolik und
dies die Semiotik und die Bezüge zum
Französischen,
also sprachen wir eigentlich über das
sehr verwandte Konzept der Repräsentation
und tatsächlich über diejenigen, die all das unterstützen
und oder ablehnen und oder Widerspruch
und Verbindung finden  Oben wird
die Diskussion um
Inaktivismus und die
Inferenzrechnung sehr stark von der
Frage der Repräsentation und kognitiven
Repräsentationen abhängen, was diese sind, wo oder
ob sie existieren und so
weiter  Nur visuell darlegen, wir werden
ihrer Ansicht nach bald mehr Darstellungen sehen,
einige der Unterschiede zwischen
traditioneller sozialer Kognition
und inaktiver sozialer Kognition,
und so statt nur einer visuellen
Interpretation des
Bildnamens  Sie unten im nächsten Okay,
also hier, was ich sehe, ist, dass in den
traditionellen sozialen kognitiven Schlussfolgerungskonten
die Zahnräder laufen  drehen sich im Gehirn
und dann gibt es Wahrnehmungs-Aktionsschleifen
und Verknüpfungen, die soziale
Einheiten verbinden, die in ihrem Körper sind, aber der
Körper wird als Schnittstelle
für diese Art von Information angesehen, die
eine extreme Haltung oder einfache visuelle
Darstellung überträgt
und dann hier im Gegensatz wir  Sehen Sie, wie
die Zahnräder überall sind, auch in
der Umgebung, in der Nische, im
Zwischenraum,
und dass das Gehirn zwar Dinge tut,
aber auch Teil eines inszenierten
Systems ist, das diesen kultivierten
sozialen kognitiven Prozess ein bisschen
mehr in einem ganzheitlichen Rahmen umsetzt so  Dean, ja
ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, dass
wir uns gleich ansehen werden, worüber
die Entführungssache spricht, aber im
Moment möchte ich, dass die
Leute sich einfach die Vorstellung vergegenwärtigen, dass
dies mit einer Art von spricht  zeitliche
Tiefe, aber diese zeitliche Tiefe ist
vertikal.
Ich denke, die Entführung, wenn man sich längere
Zeitlinien über Hunderte von Jahren ansieht, ist eher
horizontal, also denken Sie einfach daran, dass
wir Tal sind  König der zeitlichen Tiefe, aber der
Fokus liegt auf einer vertikalen oder tiefen
zeitlichen Tiefe statt auf einer breiten lateralen
zeitlichen Tiefe.
Beide sind wichtig, aber sie sind orthogonal
, was nicht bedeutet, dass sie miteinander in Konflikt stehen,
es bedeutet nur, dass sie
gehen  in verschiedene richtungen, das ist alles, was
ich dazu sagen möchte,
es ist lustig links und rechts oder west und
ost, das sind gegensätzliche richtungen, aber
sie sind keine negativen richtungen, und
genau dort beginnen wir zu sehen,
wie orthogonalität oder spärlichkeit
oder bedingte unabhängigkeit
gewährt werden  Zum Beispiel durch eine Markov-Decke,
wie diese im Rahmen
von Gegensätzen, aber nicht Negationen zu sehen sind.
Stephen
und dieses Zahnrad im Diagramm auf der rechten Seite,
dort das Zahnrad dazwischen, das
Sie kennen, das zeitliche Tiefe
haben kann, die diesen Geist-Körper haben kann  Das
Umgebungsstück ist definitiv vorhanden, wie Sie
sagen, und stellt offensichtlich eine
Analyseeinheit dar, die wirklich herausfordernd ist, und ich
würde dort auch Wörter als Zahnrad einsetzen, die
Wörter sind
zucken  Das Verhexen unserer Sprachbox gibt uns
Wörter im Raum um uns herum,
also weißt du, dass sie auch als Werkzeuge verwendet
werden, also sind
wir plötzlich viel mehr verstrickt, selbst wenn es
nur Sprache ist,
ja, und es braucht Zeit, bis die
Sprache durch die Sprache geht  Internet und durch
Raum und Zeit
ein bisschen mehr Tiefe in sozialer
Untätigkeit,
diese äh Untätigkeitsforschungsressource
beschreibt mehrere Bedeutungen und Bedeutungen von
Untätigkeit
in den performativen und
hervorbringenden Sinnen, also lesen Sie bitte
und auch eine wirklich schöne Arbeit von 2009 in
kognitiver Semiotik von de bruyne  und de
haan
diskutieren einige der Beziehungen eines
Aktivismus in der sozialen Kognition,
und sie haben hervorragende Arbeit geleistet
, indem sie zusammenfassten, was die inferenziellen
und die inaktivistischen Berichte zusammenbringen können,
und
diese Verbindung gewissermaßen diskutieren. Ja, bitte, Dean,
ja, ich
habe diese Leute gelesen, weil ich sie gefunden habe  Und
hier ist eine interessante Sache, wenn
sie eine Brückenmetapher verwenden wollen.
Ich denke, ein Aktivismus hat eine Brücke,
es ist nur eine vertikale Brücke,
es ist die  Seite eines Gebäudes hoch
und so
ähm nichts, was
sie hier geschrieben haben, aber ich denke, es
gibt eine Schuld
und es gibt eine Fähigkeit zu überspannen, es ist
nur, dass es
vertikal geht, es geht nicht traditionell von einer
Seite zur
anderen  Nun zu ein wenig mehr Tiefe in
Entführung und Semiotik.
Nun,
wir hatten eine ziemliche Lernreise
zusammen
und das
Entführungspapier
mit
einem oder anderthalb oder sogar zwei der
Autoren, die echte Pearson-Experten waren,
vorausgesetzt, viele Details
Pierce war ein produktiver Schriftsteller und Denker
und Mitarbeiter und auch ein Großteil der
Arbeit war unveröffentlicht, was bedeutet, dass
es einige obskure Referenzsysteme gibt
und nicht alles
davon hyperzugänglich ist
Sie möchten
auf dieser Seite
nichts anderes zusammenfassen, als wenn Sie,
wenn Sie sich für
Pragmatismus interessieren und an
William James vorbeikommen möchten, eigentlich William  James und
Charles Sanders Pierce hatten ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass
sie vor vielleicht 150 Jahren
die ersten
Konflikte darüber waren, wie die Dinge funktionieren,
ähm, es ist wirklich ein erstaunlicher
Startpunkt in Bezug darauf, wie Menschen, die
scheinbar miteinander konkurrieren,
tatsächlich abschneiden  einander
schlauer, aber tatsächlich viele der Dinge,
viele der Ideen, auf die wir 150 Jahre
später jetzt zurückblicken,
müssten wir sagen, dass sie sich vielleicht in
Konkurrenz zueinander fühlten, aber ich denke,
was sie taten, war die Weitergabe  oder
irgendwie ein besseres Modell zu bauen, weil
sie die Dinge nicht immer mit
denselben Augen betrachteten, sie hatten beide Augen
offen, also sage ich nur, geh
zur gemeinsamen Seite, es ist wirklich gut,
ja, es ist großartig, diese Darstellung
ironischerweise
passend zu schneiden  gehört zum bekannten
semiotischen Rahmen der Pearson-Triade, in dem ein
Stoppschild das Repräsentamen genannt wird die repräsentierte
Instanz das physische Stoppschild das wirkliche
Stoppschild
das Objekt das Durcheinander ist  Alter Autos müssen
hier anhalten und der Interpretant ist, ich sollte
hier anhalten und das ist, wo wir diese Entitätsagentur bekommen.
Ich habe ein interessantes Papier
über die Benutzeroberfläche gefunden,
das einige dieser wirklich
zeitlosen Diskussionen über Semiotik und
Logik in einen digitalen Kontext bringt, den
sie anwenden  Diese Semiose zur
Metapher der Benutzeroberfläche
könnte man sich vorstellen, wenn das ein
Stoppschild in der realen Welt wäre oder wenn es eine
Schaltfläche auf einer Website im Kontext einer Benutzeroberfläche wäre,
und
jeder kann innehalten und einige dieser
sehr hervorragenden Auswahlen aus Zitaten
und ähm lesen
Vorlesungen darüber,
wie
Kopien von Zeichen und Symbolen
durch Logik und Semiose miteinander verbunden sind
, aber wir werden
speziell mit der Entführung fortfahren, also ging es ein
wenig um Pierce und die Definition
von Semiotik im Gegensatz
zur Wissenschaft der Dinge, den positiveren
Wissenschaften  und die Wissenschaft der Formen,
die die formaleren Wissenschaften sind,
was abduktive Argumentation ist,
es war sehr faszinierend, dies zu erforschen,
dies ist ein Zitat aus der Abductio  In einem Papier, das
sie geschrieben haben, ist es in der Sekundärliteratur üblich,
dass z. B. aufbauend auf Pierce
Abduktion als in
zwei Teilen oder zwei Arten auftretende
generative Abduktion und selektive
Abduktion aufgefasst wird.
Hier ist eine andere Perspektive auf die zwei
Typen oder die zwei Sorten oder
Zweikomponenten-Zweitaktmotoren  der
Entführung aus der Stanford-Enzyklopädie
äh Philosophie, die
sie in der philosophischen
Literatur geschrieben haben, wird der Begriff Entführung in
zwei verwandten, aber unterschiedlichen
Bedeutungen verwendet
das ist generative
Entführung, während es sich im zweiten
Sinn, der
in der modernen Literatur am häufigsten verwendet wird,
auf den Platz der erklärenden
Argumentation bei der Rechtfertigung oder Bewertung einer
aufgezählten Reihe von Hypothesen bezieht
und in gewissem Sinne
den Inhalt sinnvoll macht  müssen generiert werden um
kuratiert zu werden die ideen müssen konkret sein  ied
aufgezählt, um gerechtfertigt oder
bewertet zu werden,
Dekan, bitte machen Sie weiter so,
nur ganz schnell, also haben
wir jetzt Rot und Blau, was
wirklich sehr wichtig war, um hervorzuheben,
dass Sie beide brauchen, Sie brauchen mindestens
zwei, damit die Erklärung
als
nächstes abduktiv erscheint  Argumentation im
probabilistischen Sinne wird auch als
Rückschluss auf die beste Erklärung bezeichnet. Es ist eine
Form der logischen Argumentation, die auf
die wahrscheinlichste Hypothese schaut, um etwas zu erklären.
Ein Beispiel, ob die weißen Bohnen
in der linken Hand aus der Tasche mit
Objekten stammen, die in der rechten gehalten werden  Hand hier können wir
sehen, wie die aufgestellte Hypothese
von
einer unvollständigen Beobachtung oder einer
Schlussfolgerung abhängt. Gibt es auch Bohnen in der
Tasche, und selbst wenn dies der Fall ist, ist die Quelle
für das, was auf die
linke Hand übertragen wurde, so erneut zeitliche Tiefe,
wenn Sie hineinkommen  Eine Situation,
welche Art von Hintergrund und welche
Art von Kontext Sie besitzen,
wird zu dieser vierten Form
der Logik führen, die buchstäblich aussieht  Sie haben
ein ganzes Leben
damit verbracht, sich zu
entwirren und dann
zu einer Art Kohärenz zu reformieren,
und
diejenigen, die zuhören, beginnen möglicherweise,
Andeutungen früherer sensorischer Beobachtungen,
späterer Aktualisierungen von Überzeugungen über die
Welt zu sehen, sogar Handlungsauswahl, die ins
Spiel kommt, insbesondere die Übersetzung der
Angebote, in die sofortige
Handlungsverfügbarkeit  Richtlinien, die
anhand ihrer erwarteten freien Energie bewertet werden können,
aber wir werden dorthin gelangen
, wenden wir uns
der Entführung zu, und hier sind einige der
sehr faszinierenden Papiere, die auf Commons verfügbar sind und
viel mit Entführungen zu tun haben,
und um mit einer davon fortzufahren
Ressourcen von Commons über
Entführung als praktische Schlussfolgerung
von Thomas Capitan
Diese Arbeit, über
die wir nicht alles lesen werden,
geht auf viele interessante
Punkte
über diese duale Natur der Entführung
mit Hypothesengenerierung
und Hypothesenauswahl ein
und unterscheidet, dass die Hypothesenauswahl
deduktiv erfolgen kann  valide Bewertungen
jedoch die Kreativitätsphase  Das ist
nicht-inferenziell, das hat viel
Resonanz mit nicht
vorzensierten Ideen und einer inklusiven
Diskussion beim Brainstorming
und der Erkenntnis, dass es
in einer endlichen Zeitspanne von Raum
und Zeit ein Gewinnen geben muss.
Außerdem gibt es hier einige Diskussionen
Wenn wir uns auf das Prinzip der freien Energie zurückbewegen oder mit ihm verweben
, kommt das anfängliche Bewusstsein der Hypothese
mit der Beobachtung eines
zusammengefügten Ganzen durch einen
unkontrollierten Einblick in die Welt der
Ideen in das, was er Dritte nennt, wie
es in der Wahrnehmung
der neuartigen Konzeption gegeben ist  Instanz von
Prämisse 2,
die einen vorherigen Teil des Papiers zitiert, wird
durch frühere Erkenntnisse verursacht.
Sein Inhalt wird durch die Tatsachen,
Beobachtungen, Sinnesbeobachtungen
nahegelegt, aber nicht alles, was vorgeschlagen wird, wird
aus der Erkenntnis der Tatsachen abgeleitet,
und so
fährt Pierce fort, zu beschreiben, dass es
Operationen gibt  Geist, die
logisch exakt analog zu
Schlüssen sind
, wenn man nur akzeptiert, dass sie unc sind  bewusst
und daher unkontrollierbar und
daher nicht Gegenstand von Kritik, also
abgesehen von der Frage, ob
unbewusste Prozesse hier als kontrollierbar angesehen werden könnten,
sehen wir Hinweise auf Wahrnehmung sehr wohl
als unbewusste Schlussfolgerungen und
wir sehen auch Kontinuität
zwischen Prozessen der Aufmerksamkeit und
bewussten Schlussfolgerungen
und anderen unbewussten Schlussfolgerungen  und so stellt dies
in gewisser Weise auch einen
integrierten Rahmen des Wahrnehmungslernens des
Glaubens zur Verfügung, der die zeitliche Tiefe des
bewussten und unbewussten Bewusstseins aktualisiert.
All diese Merkmale werden in der
persischen Arbeit untersucht, und das Entführungspapier
wird
diese Tatsache sehr spezifisch hervorheben,
okay, ein wenig weiterzumachen  etwas mehr,
äh, Abduktion und Retroduktion,
möchten Sie etwas zu diesem
einen
Dekan hinzufügen, ich meine Leute, die es studiert und
dieses
Wunder manchmal analysiert haben, ob dies
eine
Morphologie war oder ob wir
die beiden Begriffe gleichzeitig oder wieder
austauschbar verwenden können oder nicht
es ist wahrscheinlich einer
Wenn Sie
herausfinden möchten, was die Details
sind, sollten Sie wahrscheinlich hingehen und einen Blick darauf werfen,
weil es interessant ist, aber
an dieser Stelle nicht. Alles, was wir im Grunde tun möchten,
ist,
hier zu
lesen  Viele
Logiker lehnen es ab, diese letzte Schlussfolgerung zu nennen,
da ihre Schlussfolgerung so extrem problematisch ist, dass sie
ein wenig mehr
als eine Befragung darstellt
Ich bin sicher, dass sie falsch liegen, aber sie
haben sich nicht
der wahren wissenschaftlichen
Definition von Schlussfolgerungen bemächtigt. Was er hier also im
Grunde sagt, ist, dass wir nicht
abduktives Denken infrarotes oder
induktives Denken
die logische Rechtfertigung einer
Retroduktion nennen, deren richtige
Schlussfolgerung darin besteht, dass die  vermuteter Zustand
der Dinge ist wahrscheinlich
in dem vagen Sinne, dass er dazu neigt
, dem wirklichen
Zustand der Dinge zu ähneln, und i dies ist der Teil,
wo so wh  es ersetzt diesen
Instrumentalismus,
was auch immer wir als
Instrumentalismus definieren,
das ist wieder
eines dieser Rätsel, wenn es
nicht ist, wenn es kein
realer
Zustand ist, was nicht, was dann ein
unwirklicher oder nicht-wirklicher Zustand ist, weil es
da ist, was
wir haben  bezeichnet es
was was füllt das was fühlt sich das
schließlich an das ganze zu machen das ist hier die
frage
und auch wieder lohnt es sich
einige der vorarbeiten eines der
autoren des entführungspapiers zu lesen und man kann
in ihrer forschung eine starke
entwicklungslinie erkennen und  Viele der Arbeiten erweitern und modernisieren,
lasst uns einfach
ja, also habe ich diese äh Bärenzeichen weggelassen,
weil ich eine wirklich, sehr, sehr schnelle Geschichte erzählen möchte.
Wenn Sie also irgendwo leben, wo es Bären gibt,
beginnen die Leute, das Bärenzeichen zu ignorieren  eigentliches
Zeichenobjekt
und sie werden nicht mehr zu Dolmetschern
, sie verlieren absichtlich
diese Triade, also
wenn Sie im Geschäft des
Tierschutzes sind und nicht wollen, dass sich Bären
zu sehr
an hu gewöhnen  Mann, Kontakt, Sie müssen
sehr wählerisch sein, wenn Sie das Schild anbringen
und vor allem, wenn Sie das
Schild entfernen,
also wollte ich das dort aufhängen, weil
das ein großer Teil des abduktiven und
retroduktiven Stücks ist, für das
Sie manchmal Dinge wegnehmen
müssen  entführung zur arbeit es ist die entfernung
von möglichkeiten
, die tatsächlich
eine betonung erzeugt.
ich denke, wir werden einfach mit realismus
und instrumentalismus fortfahren, weil wir
in den nachfolgenden diskussionen auf entführung zurückkommen werden,
also
hier einige zitate aus einem fair bend-
papier
Laut Realismus beschreibt solches Wissen
allgemeine oder besondere Merkmale des
Universums, was nicht bedeutet, dass
das Gravitationsmodell
die Schwerkraft ist, was nicht bedeutet, dass das Gravitationsmodell das ist, was die
Gravitationsobjekte sind,
aber ein Realist würde es tun  Beachten Sie, dass zum
Beispiel formale Modelle der Schwerkraft
uns die Existenz von
Objekten lehren, auf die die Schwerkraft einwirkt,
und die Beschreibung einer Kraft zulassen,
die es kann  nicht direkt gesehen, gehört oder
gefühlt werden, aber dennoch einen spürbaren
Einfluss haben
Kräfte sind reale Dinge sind real
nach dem Instrumentalismus
selbst eine vollkommen korrekte Theorie
beschreibt nichts, sondern dient
als Instrument zur Vorhersage der
Tatsachen, die ihren empirischen
Gehalt ausmachen,
und so weiter  Nochmals zu diesem
Gravitationsbeispiel von Newton könnten die Instrumentalisten
die Position einnehmen, dass es keine
Entitäten gibt,
Gravitationskraft und Gravitationsfelder
sind lediglich instrumentelle
Anwendungen statistischer
Argumente oder möglicherweise sogar sozialer oder
machtdynamischer Argumente,
und ein Instrumentalist kann die
Existenz von Objekten,
Entitäten und Kräften darin leugnen  Fall
und nehmen die Dinge sogar so weit,
dass sie Wörtern als
Instrumenten und den Beziehungen rund um
Kommunikation
und der Art und Weise, wie sie Sinnesdaten ordnet und vorhersagt, skeptisch gegenüberstehen
in Live-Stream-Nummer  14.
Noch eine Folie zu Realismus und
Instrumentalismus, und dann fühlt sich jeder von Ihnen
frei,
ähm,
ich werde einige der unteren noch
einmal beschreiben. Die Unterscheidung von Kartengebieten ist
sehr
wichtig für die Gespräche über Realismus und Instrumentalismus, für die
es auch eine Vielzahl exzellenter
philosophischer Arbeiten gegeben hat
Beispiel ein Nachfolger des Realismus
Anti-Realismus-Frage,
diese beiden sind übrigens
Negationen, während Realismus und
Instrumentalismus, die
wir vorschlagen, als Gegensätze angesehen werden könnten,
und auch Helen Longanos Arbeit über
wissenschaftlichen Pluralismus hat viel darüber zu sagen,
indem sie a nimmt
multidisziplinäres Objektiv auf Realismus und
Instrumentalismus
und dann Dean, würden Sie gerne
etwas über dieses Top-Papier beschreiben, das Sie gefunden haben,
äh,
ich könnte, ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, in den
großen Plänen, um ehrlich zu sein, es ist hier, damit die
Leute lesen, es gab viele Papiere
und  Auch hier stellen wir nur eine Menge
Text für diejenigen auf, die innehalten und
den Trails folgen möchten,
und alles verstrickt sich irgendwie in
Stephen An  Meine Kommentare zum Realismus-
Instrumentalismus
Ich nehme an, das Stück, das mir oft in den
Sinn kommt, ist, dass
all dies dann
auf einer bestimmten Ebene in Aktion untermauert wird, sodass
die Idee, nach
anderen
Widersprüchen oder verschiedenen
Retro-
Ansätzen
zu suchen, ein Fall sein könnte  Stellen Sie sich vor,
wenn jemand daran denkt, einen Weg
durch den Wald zu gehen
, wissen Sie, oder Sie könnten viele dieser Dinge neu verkörpern,
oder und vielleicht geht alles auf einer bestimmten Ebene
durch eine Verkörperung,
und wenn es konzeptionell ist, dass diese
Verkörperung gerade passiert  ein eher
konzeptioneller Raum
, der sich nicht auf so viele andere
ähm Geschichten stützt oder
sich durch die Dinge
vortastet, also ähm,
der Unterschied, der passiert, wenn man
in einem Übungsfeld ist, ist, dass man so
daran gewöhnt ist, darin zu sein  Praxisfeld
,
dass diese Verkörperung das Wasser wird, in dem
du schwimmst
, also könnte das
etwas sein, das sich
ganz schnell auf dieses großartige Ja Dean bezieht,
also fragen wir an dieser Stelle noch einmal Ja zu
Reali  sm
ja zum instrumentalismus
ja bis zum ende
nicht oder
rückgängig gemacht
wir hatten hier ein kleines kaufmännisches und und wir
das und hier
ähm eine kurze anmerkung zur e kognition
wir werden hier nicht in die tiefe gehen aber 4e kann
sich auf xiavio und van der beziehen
Schiff 2018 Papier, das im
Kontext der Musikpädagogik ein
sehr faszinierendes Gebiet war 4e ist verkörpert
eingebettet eingebettet
erweitert erlassen
enkulturiert usw usw usw 7e 11e 22e
alle und dann ein lustiges Zitat von Carl
Fristen
von unserem
Symposium für angewandte aktive Inferenz im Jahr
Er sagte, eine Schlüsselsache bei aktiver
Inferenz
sei, dass sie jenseits der Vorhersageverarbeitung liegt
, dass sie jenseits des Empfindungsvermögens liegt und
die pragmatische Wende zu Beginn dieses Jahrhunderts betont oder widerspiegelt, die
wirklich durch die vier E verkörpert wird
, um deutlich zu machen, dass das Empfindungsvermögen
aktiv ist
und dass Sie sprechen  über
die zirkuläre Kausalität der Auseinandersetzung
mit einem beliebigen Teilchen oder einer Pflanze mit dem,
was da draußen ist, lila zirkuläre
Kausalität, und all das ist
dann ziemlich kurz  Eigentlich werden wir
auf keines dieser Details eingehen, aber hier ist eine
Reihe von Arbeiten, die für das inaktive Papier relevant sind,
nur einige der anderen
Hintergrundzitate und andere Arbeiten, die
man sich ansehen möchte,
und für das abduktive Papier
und auch a  Ein bisschen Anlehnung sogar
an etwas, das hoffentlich die Autoren
für uns über die Rolle und
Beziehung des Nominalismus mit all dem auspacken können,
aber viele frühere Artikel der
hier
aufgeführten Autoren und wieder eine Menge großartiger Arbeit, also
danke euch Kollegen für
diese Reise
jetzt
wir können in die beiden Papiere eintreten oder den
Raum dazwischen
lassen Sie uns eine anfängliche Gegenüberstellung
der beiden Papiere haben Ich werde unser Video hier platzieren
wird die Spitze des Eisbergs sein, also Dekan,
Sie sind die Spitze des Eisbergs was würden
Sie gerne sagen  zu diesen beiden Papieren
in einer anfänglichen
Gegenüberstellung Nun, wie ich schon sagte, ich denke,
wenn Sie tatsächlich einen Schritt zurücktreten und erkennen,
dass das, was die Leute tun, indem sie sich
mit aktiver Schlussfolgerung paaren,
sagen Sie,
ich habe, ich habe eine bestimmte Art  der
Situationsanalyse, die ich
durchführen möchte, und dabei möchte
ich versuchen, Widersprüche zu beseitigen oder
Integrationen zu formulieren,
und wenn Sie an diesen Ort zurücktreten, ist
Ihr Beispiel so Ihr Ihr Hyper Ihr
Hyper äh
Ihr Kopf Ihr  Thema ist sub
uh Situationsanalyse Ihr Beispiel
passt darunter, dass
Sie jetzt nicht
den Fehler machen zu sagen, dass
meine Art und Weise, Dinge zu betrachten,
andere Betrachtungsweisen automatisch negiert oder verwandelt,
was
unter dem Titel Situationsanalyse
zu Staub führt  Jetzt
gibt es Vergleiche und sie werden hier nicht
geschrieben und sie sind so fertig, dass
ich im Grunde nur Beispiele in
jedem der Papiere ausgewählt habe, wo
Papiere über zwei verschiedene Schwerpunkte sprechen,
aber sie sind immer noch innerhalb
dieser größeren
Randgrenze von aktiv  Inferenz und wie
aktive Inferenz
sich
um das Verhalten
innerhalb eines Aufmerksamkeitsregimes herum verhält und
es für etwas öffnet, das verfügbarer ist als
das  Spezifika oder die
skalenfreundliche Sache, ob Theory of Mind notwendigerweise
mit aktiver Schlussfolgerung vermischt wird oder
ob die Idee, dass Entführung in dem Moment,
in dem ich ankomme, tatsächlich
jede Möglichkeit negiert,
Instrumente zu verwenden, um mein Wahrnehmungsfenster zu erweitern,
also werden wir es wieder nicht tun
eine ganze Menge Zeit
, um diese anderen Dinge herauszuholen, aber wenn die
Leute wirklich sehen wollen, wie man eine
Menge Ähnlichkeiten findet, wenn man ungefähr zwei Blätter
nebeneinander legt, ist
das eine interessante Übung, es
dauert eine Weile,
aber wenn man sie tatsächlich sieht  Seite an
Seite und verstrickt da ist eine
Menge Flechten im Gange
danke Dean Stephen
ja ich mag das, ähm
wie Dean darüber gesprochen hat da hast du
diese zwei Papiere es könnte fast
als zwei Eisberge gesehen werden wo
ihre Philosophien freundlich sind  von
gefrorener und
gegebener Form und Form und es gibt Sachen
darunter und Sachen darüber,
aber es gibt auch das Wasser
dazwischen,
das
viele äh Garnelen haben kann  nd alle möglichen
Dinge schwimmen herum, also
denke ich, in dieser Liste hier, wo
Sie eine Art Realismus-
Instrumentalismus haben. Nun, das sind Ihre beiden
Eisberge, richtig,
wir wollen, dass sie schön und scharf sind,
und vielleicht werden Sie ein bisschen geklopft, wenn Sie
schlagen  aus ihnen und dann okay Statistiken
und Modellvergleich
Sie wissen
, dass sie immer noch da draußen sind, aber
sie könnten ein bisschen witzig sein. Multi-Agenten-
Glaubenskommunikation
oder enge Perspektive oder wo kommen diese
Perspektiven her, um
Stochastik komplexe Systeme zu kennen
und so weiter,
ähm,
wir sind jetzt vielleicht,
ich weiß nicht, ob wir
den Eisberg nicht auflösen, es geht nicht darum, dass der
Eisberg da ist, aber wir sind  Sie sind
verschiedene Arten von ähm
Wegen
und beginnen vielleicht flexibler
und weniger stabil zu sein,
großartig, also gehen wir in das inaktive Papier
, um die Dinge vernünftig zu halten und
auch viel zu besprechen  und
zweitens haben wir wieder eine Menge Inhalt auf die
Folien gelegt, damit Sie innehalten und genießen können. Der
größte Teil des Inhalts wird
aus dem Papier kopiert und zitiert, sodass dies der
Bezugspunkt ist, um mehr zu erfahren.
Wir gehen einfach
in der Reihenfolge der Roadmap durch  Einige der
Schlüsselstücke
, die die Papiere durchgehen, werden
in Abschnitt eins des inaktiven
Papiers mit einer
Zusammenfassung
des 2020-Arguments von vessier at all beginnen,
um andere in der Welt zu verstehen, und
das wird in diesem Dokument „Think
through other minds“ präsentiert  und dann ist
Tom Theory of Mind,
sie fassen
das Argument des Denkens
durch andere Köpfe zusammen oder erfassen es als eine
Prämisse, eins ist die soziale Wahrnehmung inaktiv
und verkörpert, zwei inaktiv und verkörpert,
der soziale Akteur kann die soziale Wahrnehmung nicht direkt erfassen,
drei, alles, was nicht direkt
erfasst werden kann, muss gefolgert werden
ergo qed Schlussfolgerung Inaktive und
verkörperte soziale Kognition muss
gefolgert werden Es muss eine Schlussfolgerung über
soziale Kognition
und die Autoren der geben  Inaktives Papier
besagt, dass sich Tom durch Prämisse zwei und drei
der Tom-Orthodoxie anschließt,
um die Welt und andere zu verstehen
, was auf die Fähigkeit hinausläuft
, mentale Zustände abzuleiten und zuzuordnen
, was die äh Zusammenfassung des Denkens
durch andere Köpfe ist
und sie in Frage stellen werden
Bei dieser kritischen Analyse, dass so ein
Tom-Account tatsächlich diese glückliche
Ehe mit einem Aktivismus eingeht, werden
sie ja irgendjemanden anziehen
oder weitermachen
diese Prämissen
und welche versteckten Annahmen
diesen Prämissen zugrunde liegen könnten, wie
z. B. welche Axiome dazu führen, solche Prämissen zu generieren.
Der Widerspruch zwischen p1 und p2
ergibt sich aus zwei versteckten Annahmen in
diesem t2m-Argument, also sehen wir hier p123
oben
und dann die versteckte Annahme, auf die sich eine
soziale Erkenntnis reduziert  Information
in expliziter Aussageform
mentale Repräsentation und Zuschreibung
sie werden dies sagen sie
fühlen sich so als a  mentale
Repräsentation
und versteckte Annahmen, auch soziale
Kognition ist mit den Konzepten
und logischen Werkzeugen für Schlussfolgerungen fest verdrahtet, zum
Beispiel
bei der Geburt,
und in den folgenden Abschnitten werden
sie den
Widerspruch zwischen Prämisse eins und
zwei analysieren und klären,
diese Spannung,
ob soziale Kognition es ist.  t aktiv und
verkörpert
ist es wirklich der Fall oder ist es eine
widersprüchliche Behauptung,
dass soziale Kognition
von einem solchen sozialen Akteur nicht direkt erfasst werden kann, werden
sie dann
aus der inaktiven Perspektive kritisch bewerten, welche
Probleme diesen
Annahmen die verborgenen Annahmen zugrunde liegen könnten und
warum  Ein Aktivist lehnt diese versteckten
Annahmen ab
und lehnt daher die oben aufgeführten Prämissen
ab,
und dann werden sie untersuchen,
was diese nicht-repräsentativen
Methoden und Mechanismen der
Co-Konstruktion in sozialem Handeln sind.
Sie haben eine Markov-Decke
eine visuelle Repräsentation, die wir haben
hier schon gesehen
mit den internen Zuständen externen Zuständen
und der Vermittlung von in  Interne und
externe Zustände durch Blanket States,
die gemäß der Definition von Pearl 1988
die Blanket States sind, die die
internen und externen Zustände
bedingt unabhängig machen
und diese beiden Arten von Zuständen werden
durch ihre aus der
Perspektive interner Zustände eingehenden
statistischen Abhängigkeiten, sensorischen Zustände
und ausgehenden statistischen Abhängigkeiten definiert,
die als Aktionen oder
Schnittstellen von
der Entität oder dem Ding zur Nische interpretiert werden können,
aber wir werden auf Markov-Decken zurückkommen
und mehr später,
ja, stephen, gehen Sie
einfach darauf zurück,
eigentlich die Seite der Folie davor,
aber in Bezug darauf, wenn es heißt, dass die
Dinge nicht direkt sein können, gibt es ein
paar Dinge, die direkt verstanden werden können
nützliche Unterscheidung, denn
wenn wir an ähm denken, sprechen wir
über den Griff und  Der Griff oder eine
Zange und ich kann ein heißes Rohr nicht direkt greifen.
Ich brauche die Zange. Ich kann
eine Reihe von Dingen nicht direkt tun, ohne vielleicht
mehr als ein Werkzeug
Wenn Leute darüber nachdenken, ob
etwas
etwas ist, das explizit propositional ist
, wissen Sie, dass wir andere Arten von Werkzeugen
haben, die zum Einsatz kommen könnten, selbst wenn
wir über Wörter nachdenken,
und der Akt,
all diese Dinge zuzuschreiben, kann
Performances sein  Werkzeuge auf jeder Ebene,
also gibt
es hier eine interessante Mischung,
je nachdem, wie
der Eisberg großartig geschmolzen wird,
in Abschnitt zwei,
den Sie in der Zeitung lesen oder
hier anhalten und viele Aspekte
davon festhalten können, sie werden die Annahme in Frage stellen
dass sich soziale Kognition auf mentale Repräsentation reduziert
und
ihr Punkt destilliert werden kann, da das
Verstehen anderer eine Frage
der Fähigkeit ist, mit geteilten nicht expliziten
Bedeutungen
und möglicherweise mit einigen
Ableitungen vertraut zu sein
Ding-Ding-Ding und modellbasierte Argumentation,
die alle kontextspezifisch
modifizierbar und dynamisch sind,
und sie werden in den
weiteren Abschnitten aufdecken, dass darin
ein offensichtlicher Widerspruch zwischen den
ersten beiden Prämissen liegt, der wirklich wie
die Achillesferse ist  oder die weiche Stelle, wo
sie ihre Logik in Abschnitt zwei anvisieren werden,
sie werden diese zweite der Annahmen in Frage stellen
, nämlich dass soziale
Kognition von Geburt an fest verdrahtet ist,
und während sie dies tun, qualifizieren sie die
Position von
unten und sie sagen, dass sie es tun  beispielsweise keine
nativistische Position vertreten wie eine
rein angeborene Perspektive,
weil sie sich auf die
Entwicklungs- und ökologische Dynamik des
Kulturerwerbs konzentrieren,
stellen sie den
Erwerb des
Starterpakets in Frage und untersuchen in diesem Abschnitt auch mehr
Einige inaktivistische Kritiken von
beispielsweise fest verdrahteten Perspektiven auf soziale
Kognition
in Abschnitt 3
haben Annahmen kritisiert, die
ihrer Meinung nach hervorstechen  Der Widerspruch, der dem
Denken durch andere Köpfe innewohnt,
sie werden eine andere
Beziehung vorschlagen. Oh, du magst dieses Gericht nicht,
lass uns dieses versuchen,
und dies wird ein
Ansatz aus der Theorie dynamischer Systeme sein,
oder dst, sie schreiben
dst,
wie wir argumentieren werden  Dieser Abschnitt ist ein
Ansatz, der dazu dient, etwas über die soziokulturell situierten Praktiken von Agenten zu lernen und
Vorhersagekraft zu erzeugen, die
ihre Nische konstruieren,
da dst im Kern
nützliche Werkzeuge wie Emergenz
-Nichtlinearität und Spontaneität usw.
hat, die es uns ermöglichen, uns von
vorgefertigten Vorstellungen zu entfernen  der Tom Theory of
Mind-ähnlichen Theorien sozialer Kognition
sollte man daher darauf verzichten,
ontologische Annahmen zu machen
, die sich darauf
beziehen, wie die Dinge in der Welt sind,
also sollte man eher auf die philosophische Ontologie
als auf das Informatik-
Wissensmanagement
verzichten  diese
Art von ontologischen Annahmen,
die vom Realismus
über das Komplexe lizenziert sind  System, das auf einem nachvollziehbaren Modell basiert.
Nur weil das Modell so
nachvollziehbar ist,
bedeutet das nicht, dass wir die Lizenz
haben, ontologische Annahmen zu treffen,
da das nachvollziehbare Modell eine
Gelegenheit ist, etwas über das komplexe Verhalten zu lernen,
nur epistemische Behauptungen
sind erlaubt,
lassen Sie uns näher darauf eingehen  Schauen Sie sich die Behauptung
an, es handhabbar zu machen. Wir können ein
dynamisches System durch eine statische
Beziehung wie folgt darstellen, und hier sind
ihre Gleichungen eins, zwei und drei mit
den Beschriftungen unten,
und sie verwenden diese sehr
einfache Art wie den Kern der
dynamischen Systeme  Theorie ist zu
verstehen, wie die
Dinge davon abhängen, wie sie sich im
Großen und Ganzen ändern, und es wird auf
verschiedene Arten
in Form eines Nachfolgemodells und
eher eines Modells mit Strahl der Veränderung dargestellt.
Stephen.
Ich denke, das ist ein sehr
nützlicher Punkt, Punkt Nummer
drei  Punkt, denn es spricht auch dafür
, dass
dies ein Modellierungsansatz ist.
Lassen Sie uns sehen, was das Modell
uns sagt, und nicht eine Modellanpassung
Ansatz
ähm, das ist oft, dass Sie wissen, was am Ende
passiert, wenn Sie die definierte
Ontologie haben
, wissen Sie, dass Sie effektiv
so viele Dinge wissen, also
ähm
, das ist vielleicht ein Schlüsselstück
, das
eine Menge davon verbindet, wie Dinge in
Bezug auf aktive Inferenz überbrückt werden können und wie es
könnte  zwischen euch gehalten werden,
ihr wisst
, dass das
eine Haltung ist, in gewisser Weise,
dass es die Beine auseinander hält und
sagt,
okay,
mache ich den Spagat oder habe ich meine
Beine
richtig zusammen, also
lasst es uns herausfinden, anstatt dass
ihr mir jemand Experte sagt
und
ja, danke,
danke, Dean, ja,
ja, ich wollte nur noch etwas zu dem hinzufügen, was
Stephen gerade gesagt hat. Ich
liebe
das Papier,
dass es das konstruktivistische Stück ist,
obwohl ich denke, dass
ich
für eine Minute innehalte, weil ich das
glaube  Damit
wir diese Entscheidung treffen können,
ist es der Spagat oder ist es eine Gabelung, ist es
buchstäblich eine Gabelung, und anstatt von
links nach rechts gehen zu müssen, ist eine Dekonstruktion erforderlich
, die meiner Meinung nach oft vorher ausgelassen wird
zu einer Rekonstruktion,
also streite ich nicht mit den
Autoren, weil ich denke, dass sie
die Autonomie respektieren,
und ich denke, sie haben brillante Arbeit geleistet,
indem sie gesagt haben, okay, diese Logik, dieser deduktive
Weg, den andere Autoren eingeschlagen haben,
trifft hier möglicherweise nicht unbedingt zu  Weil
es zu viel Mischen verursacht, also gut, gut,
gut, du hältst hoch, was
tatsächlich links und rechts ist,
aber du lässt das Hinzufügen von weg,
und ein Teil ist, dass es eine Gabel sein könnte, die
ich buchstäblich aufheben könnte, und das
man kann das nur sehen, wenn man dekonstruieren kann,
bevor man rekonstruiert und dekonstruieren
bedeutet nicht unterscheiden, was
bereits vorhanden ist dekonstruieren
bedeutet wörtlich als
die einheit
wann bin ich in diesem moment angekommen was
habe ich was welche teile des puzzles
fehlen mir noch  Weil
ich es eilig habe, herauszufinden, ob ich als
nächstes nach links oder rechts gehen soll,
besonders im Gesamtkontext, besonders
dort,
ja, Stephen, wenn Sie hier einen kurzen Punkt geben möchten,
danke, nur um das hinzuzufügen
, ähm
dieser Teil der Situationsabhängigkeit,
ähm, ich
glaube, das ist es, wo Sie sich dessen
bewusst werden, was vor sich geht, also
sagt uns die Wissenschaft sehr viel, was vor sich geht,
was ist das, was ist
das, was ist das,
aber diese Weggabelung oder das Sein, wissen Sie
, ein  Team, Team, Alter, Kreuzung oder
etwas anderes,
letztendlich gibt es ein Bewusstseinsstück,
wo sich das befindet, und in aktiver
Inferenz, das oft
komplexer ist, nebulös
mit dem wissenschaftlichen Wesen über die
Genauigkeit der Methode, auch wenn
das Bewusstsein und die
Komplexität in aktiver Inferenz
beides haben kann  Ja, großartig, fahren Sie
in den letzten Teilen des Papiers fort.
Sie sprechen viel über Komplexität, die
viele von uns so lieben,
dass Komplexitätswissenschaft, Komplexitätstheorie,
so viele
großartige
Begriffe, Konzepte, Menschen, Methoden, Werkzeuge,
Ideen, alles,
und sie sprechen viel über Autopolitik
und diese Rekursivität  Es gibt also
viele wirklich kreative Verknüpfungen, die
in dem inaktiven Papier hergestellt werden, und die Komplexität ist
In Abschnitt 4 werden
sie in wirklich wertvoller Weise eingesetzt und bewegen sich
in einer inaktiven dynamischen Umgebung zu aktiver Inferenz,
und dort wird aktive Inferenz
als aufschlussreiches
Instrument eingesetzt, um die Dynamik zu lernen und zu verstehen,
die kulturellen Kokonstruktionen zugrunde liegt
Wenn man bedenkt, dass Agenten nicht unbedingt
als passive
Agenten zusammengenommen werden müssen, sind die Autoren der
Zustände voneinander
und so
ähnlich wie die
zuvor gezeigten inaktiven Figuren, wo wir die
Zahnräder im Kopf hatten
und das dann dazu führte, dass die
Zahnräder stärker verteilt waren  Im Körper und
im Geist
hier in Abbildung 2 gibt es eher eine
klassische
bedeutungs- und modellbasierte Argumentation, bei der
verschiedene soziale Akteure
diese inferenzielle Darstellung haben, die
einer Richtung sehr ähnlich ist, wie hier
mit einem Pfeil gezeigt, der nur auf die
Mitte und zeigt  in Abbildung 3 stellen sie
die soziale Aktion in Abbildung 2 unter
aktiver Inferenz dar, indem sie
hier
die internen Zustände kennzeichnen  des sozialen Akteurs
und der externen Staaten als sozialer
Akteur eins, also aus der
Perspektive des sozialen Akteurs zwei,
wo die pauschalen Zustände
als soziokulturelle Bedeutung und als
modellbasierte Argumentation eingerahmt werden,
die sich für schlussfolgernde Konten öffnet
, die
verbreitet und in Kraft gesetzt werden
[Musik]
Hoffentlich werden wir ins Detail gehen,
denn hier
unterstützen sie ihre positive
instrumentalistische Anwendung der aktiven
Schlussfolgerung in den sozialen inaktiven Raum
und dann schreiben sie, dass sie eine
soziale Szene als analog zur wissenschaftlichen
Praxis charakterisieren, indem sie fast eine falsche Charakterisierung haben
wie zum Beispiel das, was im
Labor in einem bestimmten Kontext passiert, und sogar
eine bestimmte Sichtweise auf das, was im
Labor in einem bestimmten Kontext passiert, in einem bestimmten Kontext mit einem
Komma zu versehen
und das dann zu kritisieren
und etwas ausführlicher darüber nachzudenken,
was in den Fluren
des Labors passiert  und im Keller und
in der Welt um das Gebäude
und das ist auch r  Wirklich schön verbunden
mit einigen gelben Bronbergs Arbeiten über
das antizipierende Gehirn ist kein
Wissenschaftler, der sich auch auf die
inaktive Perspektive aus ökologischer
Sicht konzentriert, nicht nur unbedingt das
Soziale, sondern das Soziale ist ein wichtiger
Fall
in Tabelle 1, den
sie diskutieren werden  ein bisschen
mehr über
einige Teiler und Inhalte von
Zellen im Zusammenhang mit der natürlichen Welt und
wissenschaftlichen Werkzeugen und Konstrukten.
Wir werden sicher in
späteren Diskussionen hierher zurückkehren, also schauen Sie sich einfach
Tabelle eins an und
sehen Sie, was Sie denken,
welche anderen Zeilen Sie finden würden  zeichnen
würden sie wie gekrümmte Linien sein
wie Buchstaben aussehen würden Sie
irgendetwas umkreisen würden Sie einige Dreiecke zeichnen
würden Sie eine weitere Reihe hinzufügen würden Sie
es zu einem Tensor machen was würden Sie sonst noch auf Tabelle eins zeichnen,
selbst wenn nur eine weitere doppelte
Begrenzungslinie zum Hervorheben  dass es perfekt ist,
wie Dean
alles, was ich sagen würde, ist, wenn Sie sich
das ansehen, fragen Sie sich, warum diese
Hyperparameter und warum
diese spät  Rals,
weil ich denke, dass
dieser Wille zu allen Arten von
Wohlergehen für mich führen wird, es hat mich nur so verdreht,
Spaß,
okay, und dann zum Schluss, bevor wir
zum zweiten Papier
übergehen, haben wir gezeigt, dass das Halten sowohl eines
Aktivismus als auch einer Theorie des Geistes
Widerspruch mit sich bringt und  Verwirrung
Dies wird offensichtlich, wenn wir
die beiden versteckten Annahmen, die
von Tom vertreten werden, kritisch analysieren, wie Theorien wie Tom,
die von Inaktivismus abgelehnt werden, diese beiden
verdeckten Annahmen, von denen sie glauben, dass sie
die Verbindung in Verruf bringen,
und
dann die ko-konstruktive
Natur und die eingebetteten und ökologischen
Komponenten wiederholen  der sozialen Untätigkeit
und der Rekursion und der
zeitlichen Entfaltung des Ausrollens der sozialen
Untätigkeit
und sie legen nahe, dass die Theorie dynamischer Systeme
und aktiver Inferenz, instrumentell
angewendet als eine Art dynamischer Systemmodellierung,
vielversprechend
ist
und ein geeignetes und ergänzendes Werkzeug ist
, um soziales Verständnis als zu betrachten
verallgemeinerte
Synchronisation auf eine bestimmte Weise gehalten,
so dass p  Aper und
es wird jetzt
mit dem abduktiven Papier gepaart, also
einen Atemzug, bevor wir in die Abduktion
übergehen, ja, Stephen
, der diesen Atemzug nimmt, ähm, der letzte Satz
dort darüber, wie es
ähm fast eine Brücke sein kann, sie sind die
komplementäre ähm
Verwendung der Theorie dynamischer Systeme
und füllen irgendwie eine Lücke, sie
füllen die Lücke und in gewisser Weise denke ich, wenn
wir über das Entführungspapier sprechen,
dass einige der Lücken nicht gefüllt werden.
Ich weiß, dass wir hier nicht versuchen, über das
Füllen von Lücken zu sprechen, aber  Nehmen wir an, Sie
füllen Lücken, die
Abduktion
möglicherweise auch empfindet, damit Sie wissen, dass
die Schönheit der Schönheit der aktiven
Inferenz und des bayesschen Ansatzes darin besteht,
dass viele verschiedene
Skalen und Modalitäten
gewichtet und gemischt werden können, um Ihnen
möglicherweise ein Gefühl
dafür zu geben, was  das Richtige zu tun
heißt also nicht, dass das eine das andere ausschließt,
großartig,
okay,
zwischen Entführungen,
die
wir verschweigen  r in ihren Zielen, dass
sie an dieser naturalistischen
Wiedergabe einiger von CS Pierces späteren,
z. B. nach 1903 oder nach 1905
größtenteils unveröffentlichten Arbeiten
interessiert sind, die die semiotischen und logischen
Begriffe des abduktiven Denkens auspacken, die
wir im Kontextabschnitt behandelt haben, den
sie anstreben  biologisches Modell
der Entführung,
das
die Nadel
webt, was auch immer es ist
, das die funktionelle Integrität des Organismus aufrechterhält,
der evolutionäre Imperativ für
die Existenz dieses Lebewesens und um
mit der modernen Neurowissenschaft kompatibel zu sein
, konzentrieren sie sich auf die Treue und die
Allianz, die wir haben  darüber gesprochen
und sie werden auch in der
Einführung das Markov-Decken-Konzept vorstellen,
das ein großartiger Punkt der
Gegenüberstellung sein wird, um ein bisschen mehr Details hinzuzufügen,
wie wenn es eine Front ist, eine Kontaktfront
mit aktiver Schlussfolgerung mit sozialer
Untätigkeit und
Entführung als diese  sind wie heiße Punkte oder
Berührungspunkte innerhalb der Schnittstellenfront, um
wirklich hineinzuzoomen, okay, wie
In diesen beiden Modellen wird ein interner Zustand verwendet
, und hier ist die aktive
Inferenzontologie von immensem Wert, denn
selbst wenn Menschen in
verschiedenen Sprachen sprechen oder wir ein
Computerprogramm haben, eine Gleichung, ein Gedicht und
dann eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit,
wenn wir verknüpfen und proaktiv sein können
Wenn Sie die Ontologie der aktiven Inferenz verwenden oder proaktiv annotieren,
erhalten wir die Fähigkeit, nicht nur zu sagen, dass
wir beide auf den Mond zeigen,
ist Ihr Finger, mein Finger, oder zeigen wir
auf denselben Finger, weil er
so weit entfernt ist und vielleicht ein bisschen
abgebissen und dein Strahl verfehlt
aus meiner Sicht den Mond
und so weiter. Stattdessen können wir tatsächlich
runterkommen und nicht
auf dem Operationstisch bluten,
sondern eher vorübergehend festnageln und
einen Attraktor finden, der uns hilft, wirklich in
diese Schnittmenge zu gehen  als
nur mit Resonanzpunkten zu schlagen und zu rennen,
ja, ich fasse das noch einmal
zusammen, indem ich sage, dass wir
die Situation besser analysieren können, weil
wir jetzt tatsächlich h  Ich habe
eine Möglichkeit, etwas
Gemeinsames
zusammenzuhalten
, also ist das alles, was ich zu dem hinzufügen möchte, was Sie
gerade gesagt haben
Es könnte dieses Verständnis
vieler Begriffe geben Das ontologische
Verständnis und sagen,
was oft ein Problem ist, wenn
etwas nicht
ausgerichtet ist, aber
einfach nicht bemerkt oder überstrichen wird. Sagen Sie,
okay, das ist anders, okay
, hier
gibt es eine ontologische Änderung  Es gibt einen
Weg, das so handhabbar zu machen,
wie wir es mit aktiver Inferenz haben, es ist
ein handhabbarer Weg, es zu tun, weil
sonst so viele ontologische
Dinge in diesem Raum
herumschwirren, was seine Schönheit ist,
dass es kognitiv nicht möglich ist,
zu finden, was Sie sind
Ich muss mir noch einmal
den nächsten Abschnitt ansehen, danke,
mit diesen beiden Lichtern, die
gemeinsam beleuchten.
Keine zwei Lichter können sich physisch überlappen,
daher muss eine Parallaxe induziert werden  durch diese
zwei lichter und schatten und alle möglichen
effekte und vielleicht ist es nicht die gleiche
wellenlänge und vielleicht gehst du
herum und verschiedene seiten haben
unterschiedliche beleuchtungen
der abschnitt ist aktiv inferenz
im licht der abduktion
das
ist ein sehr
faszinierender abschnitt
weil sie'  Wir werden dieses
fast
quasi-algorithmische,
aber sicherlich
vorrechnerische
Framework
, das in den späten 1800er
und frühen 1900er Jahren entwickelt wurde, nehmen
und anfangen,
Schnittstellen herzustellen und zu sehen,
wie es mit aktiver Inferenz zusammenhängt,
damit wir mehr hervorheben können, und wir
freuen uns darauf, darin zu diskutieren  Weitere
Abschnitte, also pausieren Sie es, wenn Sie
das alles lesen oder die Zeitung lesen möchten,
aber sie konzentrieren sich auf das späte Schema.
Ja, bitte, Dekan. Alles, was ich sagen wollte,
ist, dass es Stimmungsbeleuchtung ist, wenn Sie tatsächlich
auf den unteren Punkt schauen
Beleuchtung versucht tatsächlich,
darüber zu sprechen. Vielleicht
weiß ich nicht, ob er tatsächlich die
Formalismen hatte, um dies zu untermauern,
aber aktive Schlussfolgerungen sprechen jetzt tatsächlich
über a  Über die
Art von Energie
, die wir jetzt vielleicht
innerhalb der beiden
Einschränkungen sehen können, dass diese Idee
, zurück in den Schraubstock zu parametrisieren
,
danke, also nur ein paar Zitate, die
hier wirklich faszinierend sind,
so
in der Wissenschaftsentführung  kann mit
der Logik der Entdeckung von Hypothesen verglichen werden,
die, wie wir bereits besprochen haben, ein
generatives kreatives Element und dann eine
sekundäre selektive Komponente wie
Bayessche Modellauswahl Bayessche Modellreduktion hat,
und sie fügen sogar mit einer warnenden
Bemerkung hinzu, dass keine vollständige
Assimilation der Pearson-Entführung stattfinden
kann  Das ist ein Rückschluss auf die
beste Erklärung, die eine Hälfte
des Zweitaktmotors ist, und üblicherweise verwenden die
Leute Entführung, um sich auf
wahrscheinlichkeitstheoretische Überlegungen aus einem bestimmten Satz
wie Entführung an anderer Stelle in den Schriften
dieses späteren Schemas zu beziehen
, die nach 1903,
aber
entsprechend sind  Für Experten waren die am wenigsten
recherchierten,
die mit einer Beobachtung des
überraschenden Faktors e beginnen  lässt
Beobachtungsüberraschung aus
und schließt durch eine bedingte
Hauptprämisse in einer kohortativen Stimmung wieder eine
Stimmung,
die der Ermittler
so bezeichnete, als hätte er und recht darin,
und das heißt, dass etwas von zwingender
Bedeutung getan werden sollte
Pragmatismus Untätigkeit Politikauswahl
zunächst geweckt  durch Neugier
Unsicherheitsreduzierung Entropie
, die zur Formulierung einer Frage führt,
die semantisch ist,
und
es gibt mehr Diskussionen über die
Untersuchungsstimmung und andere Stimmungen,
ja Dekan, eine andere schnelle Sache, die
aus dem anderen Papier zusammengehört oder mitkonstruiert wird, hat
wieder
ein gemeinsames Präfix, das wir
wieder haben  Ich denke, vielleicht können Sie noch
etwas mehr davon necken, wie
wichtig das in den nächsten
Livestreams ist.
Sie werden mit dieser
Frage der Ökonomie der Forschung weitermachen,
also haben
sie drei argumentative natürlich
wirklich festgelegte Berührungspunkte mit
aktiver Inferenz gebildet  und Entführung, die
sie vorschlagen, bilden ein erstes Trio
oder eine Triade
, die die Hauptrolle spielen wird  t Um die Verbindung
zwischen aktiver und abduktiver Schlussfolgerung herzustellen,
erstens das Vorhandensein von
nicht-degenerativen triadischen Beziehungen,
dann die Verwendung der führenden
Prinzipien des abduktiven Denkens
b und drittens die Konjunktivkonditionalformulierung,
werden einige logische Formalitäten
herumgeworfen, aber
dafür sind die Streams da
In Punkt
a können Sie innehalten und den Text lesen, in dem
sie das Konzept der Markov-
Decke
oder besser gesagt
ihre realistische
Interpretation als Erste und Decken hervorheben
und
argumentieren,
dass
die Markov-Decken, die erneut
im realistischen Sinne von First und Blanket implementiert
wurden, eine deutliche Durchdringung haben
irreduzible triadische Form, die
sich auf die Grenze als Vermittler
zwischen äußeren inneren Zuständen und
damit auf die in der Semiose entstehende Drittheit konzentriert,
gibt es noch viel mehr zu sagen, aber wenn einer
von Ihnen einen weiteren Punkt für ein
Okay in b
geben möchte, gehen sie weiter
über einige der Leitprinzipien der
Inferenz sprechen
und speziell ab diskutieren  Die
Rolle der Induktion bei der Führung der Inferenz
Was ist das Leitprinzip aktiver
Inferenzen? Dann
werden sie hier einige
technische Details der aktiven Inferenz in
Bezug auf freie Energievariationen oder
erwartete Überraschungen beschreiben
und dann werden sie dies mit einigen
der primären verbinden  Quellen von Pierce und
Diskussionen über Biosemiotik, die
auch in vielen
Diskussionen verbunden waren, die wir über
Repräsentation und Bedeutung und so weiter hatten,
und
es geht noch weiter oder tiefer
mit Diskussionen über
Synechismus
sowie dieser
Frage des universellen Geistes  ist
Kraftaltern in gewisser Weise die universelle
Kognition pankognitive Dynamik
verteilte kognitive Systeme
Materie ist effete Geist von von Schiller
und dann werden sie über
makellose Decken und ihre Konstruktion
in Bezug auf triadische Beziehungen streiten
Pearson Triade Zeichen Objekt interpretieren Ameise
führt zu unerforschten  semantische
Möglichkeiten
, die einige dieser breiteren
qualitativen Fäden zusammenführen i  n Semiotische Analyse
mit potenziell dynamischer
Systemtheorie, quantitativen Bayes'schen Methoden und
allem anderen, was aktive Inferenz
mit den zu implementierenden Toolkits mit sich bringt,
und sehen
Sie, dass sie auch in c enthalten
sind  Nennen Sie es
, die
in weiteren Diskussionen näher darauf eingehen,
aber sie werden untersuchen,
wie sich unterschiedliche
Rahmen logischer Beziehungen
zwischen Klauseln oder Behauptungen und
Haftbefehlen und all diese Rhetorik
auf die
Entführung
des Realismus beziehen und die Version von Realismus durchbohren, da das
Mögliche das ist, was tatsächlich werden kann
Ja, es gibt Dinge, die möglich sind,
aber nicht tatsächlich werden können, und was
verwenden wir dann für dieses angrenzende oder
realisierbare
Mögliche,
und
wo möchten wir es möglicherweise verwenden und
was wird diese Symmetrie brechen, wo ist
Pragmatismus, was sinnvoll wäre, zu
berücksichtigen  der Raum aller
Möglichkeiten, die passieren könnten und nichts
anderes und n  Lassen Sie sich nicht von angrenzenden
Möglichkeiten überraschen, die wir nicht in Betracht gezogen haben, die
aber eingetreten sind,
und dann ist es vielleicht nicht so schlimm,
ein wenig zusätzliche Gedanken oder ein paar
zusätzliche Computerressourcen darauf zu verwenden, Möglichkeiten in Betracht zu ziehen
, die nicht eintreten könnten,
aber wir nicht wollen würden  sich im
potenziell exponentiellen Raum von
Möglichkeiten zu verlieren, die nicht passieren können,
und am Ende unseren Fokus und unsere
Aufmerksamkeit auf Möglichkeiten zu verlieren, die passieren können
, was Pierce
als reale Möglichkeiten beschreibt,
und die pragmatische Haltung
und
Stimmung schließt auch den Kreis mit der politischen
Auswahl und  Pragmatismus in aktiver
Schlussfolgerung,
wo sie sagen, dass die pragmatistische
Bedeutung von Überzeugungen in der Bane-Paris-
Formulierung
darin besteht, dass auf einen das reagiert, worauf man
in der Lage ist zu handeln,
und es gibt viele Resonanzen,
Stephen,
ja, ich denke, das spricht dann auch für
die Notwendigkeit, etwas zu haben
wir sprechen von skalenfreundlichen oder Ebenen
oder
Sie kennen eine Art Struktur, die es
ermöglicht, dass
dies vorhanden ist, weil
Sie wissen, dass aktiver Einfluss so sein kann  Es geht
ganz nach unten und wird auf
die zelluläre Ebene gebracht, da es hier Möglichkeiten gibt,
es zu betrachten
, gibt es ein Gefühl, dass wir uns
diese äh
Ideen von äh einem Signifikanten ansehen,
aber wir wissen mit aktiver Schlussfolgerung,
dass es nicht so ist  glaubt, dass wir eingehende
Signale haben, die verarbeitet
und aggregiert werden,
also gibt es eine Art Skala, auf
der Sie die Strukturen haben, dass
Sie die
Morphogenese haben, vielleicht um auf
eine Skala zu kommen, damit
das Stoppschild Sinn macht
, um als es interpretiert zu werden
Eigener
Signifikant, also denke ich, dass
dort diese Spannung
zwischen den Inaktivisten hier und und
wo das passieren kann, sein könnte, aber das Argument
könnte gut sein, ich würde sagen, dass bestimmte
Skalen
bestimmte Strukturen
und vielleicht bestimmte realistische
Arten von Dingen passieren, so
etwas wie  das
ist machbar
super nur dean und dann gehen wir schnell
durch den rest lass mich hier nur ganz
schnell sein ich denke besonders in b
und und bis in geringerem umfang und c
der bus  Die Art und Weise, wie wir durchdringendes
durchdringendes
Denken
in den Bereich aktiver Schlussfolgerungen bringen,
basiert auf einer Annahme, und das heißt,
dass das Fortbestehen unserer fortwährenden
Existenz unsere fortwährende
Realität
bedeutet, dass wir mehr
Erfahrungen mit den Werkzeugen
in der Welt der Regeln sammeln  Welt und
die Pools und mit Pools meine ich diese
Ansammlungen, auf die Stephen gerade
hingewiesen hat, um Ihnen dafür zu danken, dass Sie das erwähnt haben,
Steven, weil ich das dazu gebracht habe
, diese Ansammlungen als
Dichten niederzuschreiben, die
Geschichte von zwei sich materialisierenden Dichten,
also kenne
ich Sie nicht
ausschließlich sagen, dass alles real ist, und
dann sind auch alle Beispiele darunter
real, weil sogar Pierce selbst
sagte, dass es einen Aspekt dieser
Realität gibt, den wir niemals
als etwas anderes
als
Nicht-Realität beschreiben
können, obwohl wir ihn im Grunde verwenden  es,
also, wie macht das,
wie ermöglicht das,
dass sich diese Dichten bilden, und ich
weiß, das klingt so, zum Teufel, und da
raus, es
tut mir leid, aber es ist so  Eigentlich etwas, über das
wir nachdenken müssen,
danke, dass
sie dann
das Skript oder zumindest die Syntax umdrehen
und über Abduktion im Lichte aktiver Schlussfolgerungen sprechen.
Hier beginnen sie mit dieser
Anerkennung des Zweitaktmotors
mit generativer Abduktion und  selektive
Entführung,
und dann werden sie dies
mit einem Teil der Ontologie der aktiven
Schlussfolgerung verbinden, indem sie
selektive Entführung
als einen Stichprobenprozess sehen
und verstehen, wo die generative
Entführung hineinpasst, also fahren Sie
damit fort, die Entführung
aus dem Licht der aktiven Schlussfolgerung zu sehen
Wir könnten sogar sagen,
wie
Framing oder Entführung
aus der Perspektive der Ontologie der aktiven
Inferenz zu betrachten
, anstatt uns
selbst
als Interpretation der aktiven Inferenz als
ein
Konzept zu wählen, für das wir nicht unbedingt
sprechen können, für ein Konzept, für das
wir aber nicht sprechen können  wir
können englische wörter verwenden
und müssen daher nicht
unbedingt für active infe sprechen
Obwohl ich der Letzte bin, der sagt, was diese
tun oder nicht tun sollten, ist
es möglich
, die aktive Inferenz-Ontologie zu verwenden, und
dann ist es eine Art zweistufige
Checkliste,
war der Begriff im Akt der Inferenz-
Ontologie in der Kernergänzung oder
Involvierte
Abschnitte wurden
auf eine pragmatische Weise verwendet, die
in dieser Situation
in diesem Kontext mit mehreren Skalen Sinn machte,
und das ist eigentlich ein zweistufiger Prozess
, um zu fragen, ob wir
mit aktiver Schlussfolgerung sprechen, anstatt ob
wir sprechen  wie ein Anwalt oder
wie ein Verkäufer für aktive Schlussfolgerungen
per
se und sie werden den Fall in
Bezug auf das FAP-Framework im Sinne
von und unter Verwendung der Begriffe neu
formulieren und sie werden die
Beziehung von internen Zuständen
zu externen hervorheben  Zustände, die durch die Decke vermittelt werden,
und sie durchlaufen dann diesen Syllogismus
und sie restrukturieren und formulieren ihr
qualitatives Schema der abduktiven aktiven
Schlussfolgerung neu
und sie beschreiben diese
Aktions-Kognitions-Wahrnehmungsschleife
,
wo
ein Surp  risal jede eingehende
sensorische Information erlebt wird
und dann
nehmen sie das nicht nur in die passive
oder sogar aktive Interpretation davon
im Kontext eines bayesschen generativen
Modells auf
, sondern etwas, das sich
in dieser Stimmung des Ermittlers entfaltet, den
sie weiterführen
und einbringen  äh, wichtige durchdringende
Idee der Ökonomie der Forschung,
also gehen wir das hoffentlich noch einmal
mit den Autoren durch,
ähm, es bezieht sich auf Pierces Theorie der
Wissenschaft
zwischen Nutzen
und Kosten
und speziell
auf Forschung in diesem sozial
verordneten pragmatischen Sinne bezogen werden,
indem gefragt wird, wie bei gegebenem Geld-,
Zeit- und Kraftaufwand,
was den
wertvollsten Erkenntniszuwachs
bringt, zu welchem Experiment, das meine Augen hinreißen könnten  haben die meisten Informationen darüber
,
welche Experimente der Forscher
durchführen könnte, um seine Unsicherheit zu reduzieren
Das Wichtigste am natürlichen System ist,
nicht nur etwas zu verifizieren, von dem sie wissen,
nicht nur etwas zu verfälschen, von dem
sie wissen, dass es verfälscht wird, sondern
in diesem optimalen Experimentierraum zu existieren
und dann zu durchdringen und später die
Autoren zu naturalisieren
und in den sozialen Kontext zu bringen  kognitiven Bereich,
indem wir gut fragen, wie Geld, Zeit und
Energie passieren, denn dieses optimale
Experiment ist kultiviert und es verbraucht
Energie, es verwendet Reagenzien, also
könnten wir vielleicht auf diese Weise sagen, dass Pierce
einer der ersten modernen Programmmanager
für eine große Finanzierungsagentur war, aber  Nein, das
war er nicht, und sie diskutierten diese Ökonomie
der Forschung ein bisschen mehr.
Sie beschreiben in diesem Abschnitt,
wie Pierce
mehrere
Werte oder Tugenden oder Qualitäten fördert
, die die Ökonomie der
wissenschaftlichen Hypothesenbildung
in Komplexität charakterisieren,
die wie eine risikomindernde
Breite ist,
die zu spricht  Vereinheitlichung
und Vorsicht
als ökonomische Qualität der Vermeidung
sinkender Grenzerträge
durch geschicktes Breaki  Fragen
in eine Reihe kleiner Fragen
zerlegen, die mit vertretbarem Aufwand beantwortet werden können,
wie viele interessante Fäden zusammengeführt werden,
zum Beispiel Fragen,
die in binäre Ja-Nein-Fragen heruntergebrochen werden,
können hier auch mit Informationstheorie
und Quantentheorie verbunden
werden, Dekan  Ich lasse Sie fair
sprechen,
ich lese es nur fair vor und so
kurz am Anfang dieses Papiers
gibt es keine instrumentalistischen
Interpretationen von Fep und seinen
Zutaten wie Markov-Decken,
aber
dies ist eine Fußnote in diesem Papier, aber unser
Glaube  für ein besseres Wort und
realistische Referenzen von FEP als seine Wurzeln
im pragmatischen pragmatistischen Optimismus oder
besser gesagt seinem Akt des Ameliarismus über die
Gewinne aus der Allianz zwischen
evolutionären, evolutionär nützlichen
Prozessen, um zur Maximierung des Überlebens beizutragen,
wenn dieser pragmatistische Ansatz des Realismus
den Hochgestellten missfällt  Geschmack von jemandem,
der nach einigen strengen metaphysischen Kriterien sucht,
lassen Sie tausend
Blumen bl  Oom, ich denke, das Faszinierende
daran ist, dass
die Idee, dass es einen Realismus
gibt, eine sehr leicht zu verteidigende Position ist
, aber selbst auf der vorherigen Folie
eines der Dinge, über
die
zuerst gesprochen wurde, ohne sie
direkt oder zumindest nicht zu sagen  Diese Zitate
waren,
dass diese optimale Position ein
Element der Ausbeutung oder Wirtschaftlichkeit
oder Einfachheit ist oder dass jemand
vor mir dies getan hat,
dass eine Abkürzung
und Erkundung, die tendenziell
länger dauert, mehr
Versuch und Irrtum
erfordert, aber auch nicht dazu führt, dass Sie
ständig überpassen
zu einem bestimmten Ergebnis,
also
ähm
, das ist die Realität,
und wieder würde ich nicht
die Behauptung zurückdrängen, dass es ein sehr
reales
Stück zu diesem
Spiel gibt
, mindestens zwei,
die in diesem Spiel hin und her gehen,
ähm,
also
bin ich  nicht nur ich stimme
diesen autoren voll und ganz zu, so wie ich
den anderen autoren
über die idee einer co-konstruktion völlig zustimme
, also weiß ich nicht, dass
du du du bist
du bist unbedingt verwirrt wenn  Sie
können ja und ja und nochmals ja sagen,
Steven,
ja, irgendwie etwas zu dem hinzufügen, was dort gesagt
wird, und
die Idee der
Implementierung oder
Ausbeutung wird definitiv angespielt
,
und in der Wissenschaft
gibt es
Experimente, eine Art Weg
, um Wissen zu erlangen,
aber es gibt das Erkundungsstück und
Ich würde argumentieren, dass
man
per se keine Erforschung in
der Art von
objektivem Bereich erreichen kann, es muss diese
Reise in das
performative Subjektive ins Subjektive
Liminal geben,
wie Einstein es mit seinen Gedankenspielen getan hat, all
diese und du erschaffst diese Art  von
mentalen äh konstruiert in gewisser Weise, was einiges
von dem, was heute passiert, ist eine
Mischung daraus und dann wird das zurückgebracht
und modelliert, mit was auch immer experimentiert,
also denke ich, es gibt ein Ich meine, Modellieren ist
interessant, weil
es äh, es kann irgendwie auf dieser
Reise kommen a  ein bisschen auch
,
also könnte das etwas sein, was
Experimente nicht können.
Hier ist eine Zusammenfassung eines alten Witzes, Person a
sagt a
und der Ref  eree sagt du hast recht person
b sagt b der schiedsrichter sagt du hast recht
und person c sagt gut a und b können nicht
stimmen und der schiedsrichter sagt du
weißt dass du recht hast
es ist ein kleiner schneller humor für die die das
mögen  Genre
ähm, sie haben dann einen Schlussabschnitt
und
wir haben viele Fragen und Punkte zu
machen und viele Verbindungen, die wir
zu vielen Einbürgerungen hier
zurückbringen können, wie die Felder in der Levin-
Arbeit, und sie bringen es sogar zu den
Regenerationsfähigkeiten von Plattwürmern
Von
Plattwürmern zu Mitbewohnern
, dorthin gehen wir heute,
und dann haben wir auch
einige der Nebeneinanderstellungen des Markov-Deckenkonzepts für den Punkt aufgespart,
insbesondere
die sozialen und aktiven Komponenten der
Wissenschaft, die super wichtig sind und
Majeed dazu gebracht haben
Vorhergehende Diskussionen sind ein toller
Kontaktpunkt mit dem abduktiven Papier und
dem sozial inaktiven Papier
Markov Blankets stellen gleichsam eine sehr
eingeschränkte, auch fachliche
Kontaktfront dar, die für viel Diskussionsstoff sorgen wird
ion im punkt eins
und hier
schließen wir den punkt null
mit ähm
wieder so viel exzellenter grundarbeit und
rucksackpacken
von dean und steven, also
gibt es noch etwas, das sie an dieser stelle hinzufügen möchten
oder was sich ergibt,
das sie besprechen möchten  Punkt eins, ja,
Dean, dann Stephen, wenn Sie möchten, Daniel,
fantastische Arbeit, wir haben gerade eine Größenordnung von
3 aus einem normalerweise
einzelnen Live-Stream gemacht, und wir haben es immer
noch in weniger als zwei Stunden geschafft, damit Sie
Sie sind  Dafür muss man applaudieren, und
zweitens möchte ich nur
als kleinen Tipp für den
Punkt, dass es eine Forschung
namens Israel Israel Nunez gibt, die darüber spricht,
ob Sie in der Lage sein möchten, zu
sehen, wie die Dinge dekonstruiert werden  und
konstruiert müssen Sie sich beide
Produkte im Prozess ansehen, ein Beispiel dafür ist, wie
ich ein Auto baue
und im Produkt verarbeite,
was
das ist, was entweder ein
Verzweigungspunkt oder ein tatsächliches Utensil ist,
und wenn Sie sich
öffnen  sowohl diese Umkehrung
entlang
Kontinuum eröffnet es alle möglichen Möglichkeiten
, Dinge an einen Ort zu bringen, an
dem sie nicht unbedingt in
Konflikt geraten, ja, sie können sich in Zöpfe integrieren,
und vielleicht wird das
nach heute
etwas sein, das Menschen, die
aktive Inferenz verwenden, was in meinem  die meinung ist
sowohl produkt als auch prozess und prozess und
produkt
zugleich es ist der greifer und
der griff vielleicht
denken sie darüber nach
es ist fast so als ob der pragmatiker die
gabelung im weg sieht und sie nutzt
und vielleicht sie  Verwenden Sie die Gabel, indem Sie in eine
Richtung gehen, und vielleicht heben Sie sie auf.
Vielleicht verwenden Sie sie, indem Sie den Tisch für jemand anderen vervollständigen, der dort
zu Abend isst,
und daher gibt es so viele Verwendungsmöglichkeiten,
da die Verwendung
sozial erlassen wird, abduktiv
kontextualisiert usw.
und wieder  Gabelung
ist der Ort, an dem dieses Gespräch stattfindet,
und an unserem Feldstandort oder im Basislager
können wir uns die Gabelungen und die
Straßen vorstellen, auf die Stephen stoßen wird,
ja und als nächstes in der  Punkt eine
Art, einen Weg
zu finden
, die Autoren zu bringen, wenn jemand da ist, den Sie
kennen, auf einer kleinen Reise, vielleicht
eine der Gabelungen hinunter, vielleicht geht es bis zum
Rand des Sees, und wir müssen
einsteigen und ein bisschen nass werden,
also wie  kann wissenschaftliche
Entführung oder irgendeine Art von mehr
wissenschaftlich begrenzten
Modellen Regeln sein, die durch
Experimentieren und Instrumentieren untermauert
werden
?  Ich frage mich, ob Sie darüber
nachdenken sollten,
wie wir
klare
Reiseoptionen anbieten können, damit sie
ein wenig davonkommen können, ohne
in Treibsand stecken zu bleiben oder
im tiefen Wasser zu ertrinken
Also wollen wir irgendwie navigieren,
aber ich denke, das sind
einige dieser ähm-Hinweise, an die ich denke,
wo es auch eine
Art
Waze-Ausfahrten gibt  auffahrten also
danke danke kollegen
danke danke
das war riesig ich schätze wirklich
all deine hilfe
super mal wir sehen uns in der doll one
you